all right all right people of the
internet
man let me tell you guys I'm feeling a
lot better
I'm feeling a lot better
how's everybody doing on this
Tuesday evening
oh come on we gotta have hold on hold on
we gotta have the there we go
foreign
dude we gotta have the intro
welcome everybody welcome back
did I say we already have do we already
have a super chat here
all right so my screen remember we had
some technical issues
for those of you who are here the last
stream we had some technical issues
so I had to kind of reset everything up
here you see we've kind of camera angle
slightly different a little bit
so I think
I think I have uh taken care of those
things
let me pull this
here but so in doing so I had to kind of
change up the setup a little bit so all
of my my chat box and everything
is in a different spot than it was
before
okay yeah I really I wish I could get my
chat box
over here on the OBS side but for some
reason it's
appeared right now
let's see add
yeah it normally shows up in OBS I mean
that's fine that's honestly that's minor
in the grand scheme of things just makes
it harder for me to
find all of you guys
all right here we go here we go
oh wait wait
fire tea
dude thank you so much for becoming a
channel member here
thank you very much showing some love
there you just unlocked the Emoji now
you also get discounted merch
so let's see if we can
we that was another thing I tried to add
let me see if this works exclamation
point merch
because it should pop up and show you
guys
let's see if that works
[Music]
nope it didn't work
I see expecto go in the house what's up
fire tea finally got your name
hey it showed up exactly
it showed up like fire tea this time all
right we got fandom draws in the house
tonight soundtrack is here again as well
AJ draws Bristol boy
by the way if the mic's too high too low
let me know because I I tweaked that too
we kind of we tweaked everything in our
troubleshooting
so actually I think I'm gonna turn down
the music just a bit now since we're
talking I don't want that to be too loud
Logan is back as well stream elements
the stream elements bot is in the house
and running
we got Arcane Master we got slytheray
here as well Ty Lord gun it where are my
ravenclaws at oh we usually have lots of
ravenclaws
nose of Sauron welcome back Aaron Brewer
oh Aaron's a Ravenclaw there we go Nico
what's up
Jay is here as well haven't been this
excited for a game in years I know dude
right I'm pretty pumped too
I'm pretty pumped so tonight we're
talking Hogwarts Legacy but
a little bit of a curveball tonight
we're also going to be playing
the old school Harry Potter and the
Chamber secrets on PC I'm pretty pumped
for this
hopefully everything works
I tested it out the game loaded up it
was running
hey yeah Nico thank you for uh letting
people know about the music yeah I am
using the same one that we've been using
the relaxation Harmony Celtic medieval
Tavern music this one's specifically
volume 3 but I probably need to Branch
out and look at some of the other ones
too but uh yeah we got nose of SAR on
here fire burn is here
Jay is here feathers hey welcome back
feathers
let's see if we got Jay we got
soundtrack expecto go we got Lucas here
as well welcome Lucas yeah guys honestly
like I see some of the messages getting
retracted or getting kicked
I hope it usually what it is is it's a
link if somebody puts a period and then
you don't have a space after the period
it will think it's a link so just
protect the chat I have that little
filter turned on
so just make sure and then we also we
keep it family friendly in terms of the
language if it's something other than
that though then it's unintended
last time our stream elements bot was
blocking comments that were just like
hey what's up retro
what is going on
what is happening B Barbie is here as
well
Evan is here how's it going Evan Tim R
is here in the house
[Music]
yeah some retro gaming indeed retro
record tour Retro Gaming spectacle
exactly
exactly
uh ranjeev hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly so
Prisoner of Azkaban so we are at the
very end of the game the video is done
but
on the positive side we actually
I think we have a sponsor for that video
and what I mean by I think is that
this is my first time working with like
a big brand like this I can't really say
who yet but
there's a lot of approvals that things
have to go through so at first I was
actually working with them on a Hogwarts
Legacy video
oh man this this is a good story I was
working with him on a Hogwarts Legacy
video the one that is currently on my
channel that's the dark arts
um I can't remember the exact title of
it uh how evil can you be in Hogwarts
Legacy
my fastest rising video that I've ever
had
that was originally I had planned that
as a spawn it was gonna be a sponsor
video
and it kept taking forever like the
approvals were just taking a really long
time and I said guys this is kind of a
uh
like this one's a little bit Evergreen
but it's also kind of news based around
with Hogwarts Legacy and they said yeah
it's probably going to be best if we do
a more Evergreen type video
so I was like okay then I'm gonna so I
went ahead I released the video and it
blew up
like
that would have been a good one to have
the
#add-on
but yeah so the video is done it's just
taking way longer than I expected for
the approvals and I don't think
anything's necessarily like a problem I
just think that because it's such a long
video the company that I'm working with
they want to you know understandably so
they want to see everything make sure
you're not
disparaging the company in any way so
I I've checked I've reached out today
just to say like hey what's going on
here do we need do we need to move it to
a different video
so regardless the video will come out
the final Prisoner of Azkaban video will
come out it's just a matter of of when
so
Firebird N64 Atari Commodore Commodore
64 Etc Bristol boy usually catches the
vods hey appreciate that yeah
welcome back I'm more report yeah you
missed a little bit last week but not a
lot last week was crazy man we had
at the the chat could tell that I was
not 100
I sounded a lot worse than I do right
now I mean my my allergies were just out
of control I get really bad seasonal
allergies usually like once or twice a
year I'll have these really bad
flare-ups it's really rough but the
trailer came out the new trailer came
out so I was like we have I really I
wanted to do a stream so then even
though I didn't feel good I was like
okay we can power through this and then
we just had like all these technical
issues because I was trying to record
and stream at the same time yeah
so most of what I talked about last week
I have published in separate videos so
let me actually let me pull up the
channel right now for you guys so
all right so this might be a little
strange for just one second
let me hit this here okay then let's go
over to commentary view yeah see what I
mean by like everything's moved all
around so
if I maximize this yeah um
all my overlays and everything have been
adjust it slightly so let me just move
this right here
oh I love this one dude this sounds like
Wind Waker right now
okay now I don't know why you guys
aren't seeing the uh
yeah there should be a chat box right
here too
why would the chat box not be showing
[Music]
oh I know what it is I know what it is
we got to go into filter here
hold on hold on guys professional
professional streamer
there we go
professional streamer here give me a
moment
all right so your Channel
okay so if we go to my recent uploads
here
if you missed last week you can go to
videos
and then you can go down to like we have
them all kind of separated here
uh this is just like uploads right here
but you can go to past live streams
and then there's the uh
last week right there
so you can get you can watch the whole
thing it was only an hour and 13 minutes
or I also have published videos
these three right here so this one right
here is my trailer reaction very short
just 220 just my reaction to the trailer
nothing more this is me breaking down
the Playstation blog post that came out
with the trailer and then this one right
here is like a full
re-watch of the new trailer and the full
breakdown so you can check that out too
Majestic Omen with the Super Chat yo
thank you so much Majestic omen
[Music]
thank you so much for showing support on
the channel
yeah here's that dark magic video 523
000 views
dude if that would have been the
sponsored video
I mean I kind of I had a feeling that
was gonna be a positive video but you
know
all right so I really need to be able to
see let me pull my
chat up over here there we go
yeah we're eventually we're gonna have
to kind of change this around how I have
this set up actually you know what
here's what I could do for now
I could move okay it's gonna get real
weird for a second because you guys are
gonna see obs
yeah see there we go
[Music]
all right now
let me move you back over here
and then
view over there all right perfect
actually you know what we could probably
just leave that right there there we go
just leave the Hogwarts Legacy up
all right so now let's get caught up on
the comments here
so James how's it going dude what what
is up I saw you posted the Merlin video
the Merlin video who am I kidding here
one of the mini Merlin videos also saw
the founder video that you posted nice
job
thank you
I just had like a little uh
this I I'm feeling great tonight man I
did my I didn't work out at all last
week I'd been doing really well the past
couple months I'd been working out like
two three times a week
and when I got sick last week man I just
couldn't do anything the whole week so
worked out now I got my strawberry
protein shake here
if you guys are wondering why the uh
it's not my usual Waterloo here tonight
AJ draws Hufflepuff I did not realize
you were Hufflepuff AJ
all right we got Evan here Evan agrees
about Snape
who's ready for some HP oh dude I'm way
behind I'm just now singing spectacles
comment about the HP Retro Game okay
let's catch up here
love the music hey thank you yeah yeah
we got Josh here one with a sword
see we got Tessa is back hey welcome
back Tessa Dylan in the house tonight
Dylan what is up
no hat a retro head reveal nah I've uh
I'm pretty sure I've had I've had no no
hat before in videos actually
it's right here
we'll put it on when we start gaming
people be like who is who is this dude
we are live trippy at least I hope we're
live as long as we're not having any
technical issues this week
Jessica is in the house Simeon is here
Daigle enjoy this music dude yeah I mean
it seems like we nailed the playlist
here everybody loves the music I get a
lot of comments on the music
1 30 a.m for You Bristol usually have to
watch your vods hey all good Bristol
appreciate the support
oh my goodness okay 500 wizard in some
currency
I have no idea how much this currency is
s-e-k
we just got 500 SEK I feel like I need
to look this up
are you kidding fire tea
oh my goodness
fire tea dude thank you so much
very very kind of you with the Super
Chat there fire tea says I have one
question for you what do you think the
spider is on the deluxe cover keep up
the great content as always dude fire
tea incredible donation thank you so
much for that thank you for your support
of the stream and thank you for your
question so
let me actually have this
I'm not gonna pull up these super large
version of this because I I'm just extra
cautious after last week whenever I
started accessing a lot of files on my
computer that's when we started having
all the technical issues
so let me pull up
because the uh
the deluxe edition they actually put a
really high-res version of that online
and of course I I saved it but I mean it
was it was a really
crazy to try and load that so let me pop
it over on this screen here there we go
so what fire tea is asking about here
what's interesting is there's actually
two spiders here
so over here on the right we have the
one that looks like the acromantula
this one's in the
in this version too it's right over here
on the right
but it's also here in this Deluxe so
this one looks most like the acromantula
to me
then if we kind of zoom out here
Zoom back over on this side we see what
looks to be a completely different type
of spider
completely different type of spider
okay wait I just heard another uh
Christy just gifted a membership Christy
thank you so much for the gift of
membership and it looks like it went to
day goal
Christy thank you so much for your
support of the stream and Daigle
congrats on getting that gifted
membership right there
now you just unlocked the Retro Emoji
which by the way
I'm gonna it's gonna it's gonna be hard
to keep up with your old support because
I are we've already unlocked two more
Emoji slots guys
we've unlocked two more so I just I just
added four more working with an artist
so we've unlocked two more slots I don't
have any new ones just yet
but yeah this spider over here
so
I think this one's definitely acrome
Angela
and I think this one if if expecto go is
still here I think he talked about what
exact spider this may be it was a spider
that they actually
first
was in a video game like for the Game
Boy or something
it was some obscure Harry Potter title
where this uh
[Music]
where these other spiders came about so
I think it's very possible that we're
gonna have multiple types of spiders I
do
that's what I'm thinking
sorry you're late Jake hey all good Jake
a wizard is never late just a guy is
here as well Majestic omen
jams are rocking
oh expect to go catch up on the content
after being out of town yeah I hope you
had a good trip oh man nothing serious
you know when I was sick but yeah just
like the allergies knocked me down good
for a while
and then I'm hoping fingers crossed will
make sure that the uh all the technical
issues are ironed out tonight Amore poet
James took it upon himself to personally
try to convince me about this whole
Merlin Theory I was honored and he
wanted to convince me so badly
Ashley I heard about the map
from wife once a wizard I have not had a
chance to look at it yet
but I have
knowing wife wants a Wizard's videos I
have no doubt it is extensively detailed
no doubt whatsoever Ronan says how do
you get these games
um
are you talking about the old school
game if you talk about the old school
game I'm always unclear like on
how much you're allowed to say on
YouTube in terms of
emulation and that sort of Technology
but if you just go and Google
Harry Potter I think it's Harry Potter
PC
or no no no Google this medium
m-e-d-i-u-m
silver laid
s-i-l-v-e-r and then l-a-i-d-e I think
it is Harry Potter
this person put up a medium article with
all of the details laid out for how to
play the first two games
on
the first PC games on Windows 10.
yo thank you so much oh man the name
already went away where'd it go
come back
there it is
sithra missed my previous Dono oh
oh no I saw I I thought I'd call that
one out
I thought I'd call that one maybe I
missed the comment with it though
thank you so much Citra you did not have
to donate again my my apologies that you
missed that I missed it thank you so
much for your support of the stream glad
to see you're feeling better much love
from Slytherin I wanted to send another
one hey thank you so much and I I do
apologize that I missed it
yeah I'm still trying to figure out my
uh everything's showing up in the wrong
spot right now but
we'll figure it out we'll figure it out
so yeah if you um you know download
files and all that at your own risk
don't you know be you got to protect
yourself out there Jake's playing death
Loop nice soundtrack how do I become a
member so if you're on mobile
all right let's let's test this again
exclamation point join this should this
one should definitely work right here
why is that not working
okay there he goes it just took a second
and it usually posts this in two yeah
there it is
so I tried to include the details there
because I know most a lot of people
watch on mobile
desktop's a lot easier
mobile is you have to go to like the
channel page
and then go to the top and there there
should be like a join button there there
somewhere
all right
oh dude I'm so sorry guys I'm getting
behind here
getting behind
okay wait so there we go that's when
Daigle got
the gifted membership nice nice
Claymore is here hello Claymore welcome
Chrissy Gene Dyer in the house I think
Christy's actually the one who uh
who gifted
Robert I imagine it depends on what kind
of spider species the dark wizard right
yes
yeah I mean it definitely seems like
we're getting multiple spiders though
definitely seems like multiple spiders
always nice how people do that this
channel has a great Community I think so
too careless I think so too Aether 13x
or ether I think it's eight Aether
thank you so much for becoming a channel
member I think you just got did you got
you got gifted one from Dylan there
all right we got we'll put the Hat on so
newcomers don't get confused about who
is this
make it we make it nice and obvious
there
make it nice and obvious
it's kind of like a uniform now you know
I just
I feel like I have to I just don't feel
complete without it
oh yeah Bristol you like this the
shocked Sorting Hat cocoon spider thank
you expect to go yes
because they're in the uh I think it's
the ASMR right where we see or know the
uh
the the Sebastian trailer
dude we see those spiders who have like
that one person who's just bound
[Music]
yeah we got Merlin emo we got Deathly
Hallows email we got a laughing house
elf
pick the house off you want it to be I
guess we got an angry Vaulty
we've got the shocked Sorting Hat
Nara
I think that's pronounced right
I had a I had a friend in high school
named Nara that was how it's pronounced
welcome welcome
zabin or xavin yeah I hope I hopefully
you heard my answer about the the PC
answer there just Google medium silver
blade Harry Potter
and should come up with an article that
explains how it could be done for one
who may be interested in doing that
Ronan asked the same question again nice
there we go yeah we got you we got you
Ronan
[Music]
see this is like when I get so far
behind like I see a comment from Christy
wait I'm sorry what
so my I have no idea what she's talking
about
oh man and I think we just got another
Super Chat from James James Lowry James
thank you so much for the Super Chat
thank you very much for your support of
the stream dude you guys you guys are
going crazy with the memberships and
super chats already tonight what's up
retro well Hogwarts Legacy have original
score or use some of the movie
soundtrack
I think it's gonna be mostly original
if not all original let's um
let me mute
so they did confirm
[Music]
they did confirm that the music you hear
in the house
common rooms the common room trailers
they did confirm
that that music is
original and it's for the game
so let me uh mute this music here for a
second let me hop over here
so let's go Hogwarts Legacy common room
let's see which one has the most views
now it was Slytherin for a long time
wow they're actually pretty close so
Slytherin 570
Gryffindor 491 Ravenclaw 453
Hufflepuff is
excuse me 429. but I mean honestly
surprisingly close all right so I'm
Gryffindor so I'm gonna go Gryffindor
here all right so I'm gonna turn this up
so that music you hear right there
that is that is official and we'll be in
the game
but thank you for the Super Chat James
LOL boss says you said in your videos
that you think there will only be one
year in the game I think there are more
explain why they said in the trailer
that they're going to be seasons
right they did yeah
but then they also said as the school
year progresses
so there's there's a lot of things in
the
I'll tell you there's another reason I
think it's going to be only one year
another reason that I I think that now
so if you guys missed this actually
we're in the perfect trailer for it
right now I didn't intend for this but
we are we're in the perfect trailer for
it
so in this trailer for The Gryffindor
common room
I'm not gonna go through the whole
details of the chudley Cannons thing
that's in another
I break that down in another video but I
will go to this section right here
let's back it up a little bit
and then we're gonna let it go right
there okay so see this Charlie cannons
poster with the 21 on it
so because of this poster a lot of
people took that as oh man
it's got to be more than
three years or gotta be more than one
year
and our math was correct however
however
oh can the res go to 4K yeah I could
call oh I do have it on 4K
it's just not going to come through as
4k on the Stream
because I'm streaming it at 1080 but
so
Troy Levitt former Hogwarts Legacy Dev
tweeted about this
and he says he doesn't work there
anymore of course but he said
that he had passed this on to the team
that was in charge of like
continuity or something like that
so to me
I think that it's a mistake
I think it was a mistake
and he saw all the fans talking about it
I mean Avalanche probably had already
seen it too but coming from someone like
Troy who previously worked there
I think it's a mistake so I don't know
if they'll change the number or maybe
it's it's set maybe it says something
completely different I mean really all
they would have to change is
the number of championships so
all right fire burn you've seen the map
nice
oh the map that uh wife once was worked
on
can you play these games on Apple PC now
that I have I am not sure
you definitely could play them like the
um
you definitely could play the console
ones but I don't know about I don't know
about the PC ones
I feel like they made at least the first
one for Apple actually
laughs
Gabe thank you so much for stopping by
and hanging out all the way from Puerto
Rico
dude hope everything's all right there I
was I saw some article about how
was there just a hurricane there
oh yeah
um can't stay for too long need to say
battery power hopefully everyone
watching for Puerto Rico is doing okay
not affected much by Hurricane yes I saw
about that like how for a while all of
Puerto Rico had no power at all dude
that is crazy stay safe
all right let's go and watch Slytherin
too we might as well just let them play
here
all right I'm gonna get caught up with
comments here watch this watch this all
right rapid fire here rapid fire okay we
got James's there oh man
and there comes another Super Chat
just when I was like okay we're gonna
get committed we're gonna I'm gonna
commit I'm gonna commit we're gonna get
caught up with comments right here
Trey dude thanks so much Trey for your
support of the stream with the super
chat right there Trey says is it going
to be cross-platform absolutely Trey
absolutely it is going to be on
pretty much every platform it's on PC
it's on PS5 it's on PS4 it's on Xbox one
it's on both Xbox series s and x and it
is even on the Nintendo Nintendo switch
almost said Nintendo twitch
unfortunately
we do not have a release date for the
switch version yet so the switch version
I wouldn't say the switch version is up
in the air they still seem committed to
it but we do not know a lot about it
do not know a lot about that one at all
so
but yeah good news on the on the front
that it is coming to all systems there
is some
oh wait no no no it's
Minaj Niraj Niraj okay
my bad my bad yeah I had a friend in
high school who I think it was you know
what maybe it was n-i-r-a-j
Nara
Niraj Niraj I mean it rhymes with Mirage
a little bit is that right
Christy with another gifted membership
let's see who got this one welcome to
Trippy Moon just got a gift of
membership
Christy thank you so much for showing
the love spreading the love so everybody
can get access to the uh our fun little
Emoji by the way guys so you can also
use these emoji on comments of my videos
I wish they would open it up because on
Twitch you can actually
like if I'm a sub on somebody's stream I
can use those emotes or Emoji whatever
you want to call them I can use those as
any on anybody's stream here it's like
you can only use them on mine
and YouTube I mean YouTube is a lot
bigger and there's also the existing
videos other than just streams but I
think I think that'd be cool if they
ever added that in
hey have a good night feathers good
morning wherever you may be thank you
for stopping by Ken says Merlin is
hardly mentioned in the HP books I
wonder how they're going to tie his
history into the game
yo you gotta you gotta take that up with
expecto go there
[Music]
another gifted membership two games to
play two games to play welcome back good
to see you here again and thank you for
gifting a membership dude this is always
after we get the gifted membership we
always get to wait and see who's gonna
get the gift of membership this time it
goes to unrated 94 unrated congrats on
the gifted membership
thank you guys thank you very much
[Music]
ether okay
my name is
oh wait wait
see now that word I've heard that word
pronounced differently too I've heard it
as ether and I've heard it as ether I I
usually say ether
retro my English teacher likes Harry
Potter and she's a Slither and nice
Aaron says how many people have
pre-ordered the game uh dude you know
what we could do uh we could do a poll
for that
I actually like that let's do a poll
have you pre-order I'm not even gonna
break it down like deluxe and all that
I'm just gonna say just purely have you
pre-ordered
yes no ask Community boom
red Linus is back hey redlinus welcome
desktop from work for Ravenclaw Muse
tour Hogwarts you could have music from
the old games like when you're in the
library oh the happy Hogwarts music or
the library music that was different but
happy Hogwarts so good
so good
Zone M24
I'm doing well doing well
can't wait for the other things that
they have in store for us oh my gosh
you guys see Chandler's tweet from today
did you guys see the tweet from today
all right let's bring back our other
music here
dude this tweet has me so hyped
Chandler wood ladies and gentlemen it's
been a busy summer we hope you like what
we've shown so far and even with summer
at an end we're already working hard on
the next thing and the next and the next
no specifics yet but we're keenly aware
wait for it wait for it wait for it
I've been asking to see more gameplay
you guys
skylines music with the 10 super chat
skylines thank you so much for that
support with the Super Chat donation
there
do you think we are going to get a fall
ASMR video this Thursday for the start
of fall thanks as always
oh I I definitely feel like they'll do
all the seasons because
you started something now right like
they got they gotta see it through
even though it is the start of fall I
feel like it's too early
for the video
they've they've announced so much lately
you guys
so much that's why I think a lot of
people
didn't think there'd be anything at the
at the ship PlayStation showcase because
they I mean
it's just been so much
so much lately
but I mean I'd be down for it I'd be
down for it if they do but yeah this
right here that gets me so pumped
and then somebody asked let me see if I
can find the comment yeah right here
tjs says uh yes Chandler you're the best
tweet me so much just acknowledging even
if it's until January at least we know
and thank you for the subs by the way
guys thank you very much uh at least we
know something is still in the works
appreciate you Chandler says oh you
definitely won't have to wait until
January
so
what month are we in September
October November December so that's we
got three months
of basically Chandler just guaranteeing
we're getting more gameplay within the
next three months
let's go dude that's awesome
hey Jay Rossi is here as well what's up
J Rossi welcome back Fire Burns
pre-ordered
honestly curious to know if Potter has
any relatives that will be introduced
there's a Reddit post
a while back that Henry Potter who
potentially could have actually been
called Harry Potter
may have been in school around this time
I didn't get a chance to really research
it thoroughly
but I do think it's a possibility yes
Potter is not it's not as storied of a
family as say like you know Lestrange or
blacks
but it's I mean it's it's up there
it's up there
[Music]
Amore poet completely disagree that it's
one game quite confidence here's five
six and seven two years
really oh dude I
if it's that much I will lose my mind
I would lose my mind if it's I mean I
would lose my mind if it's three years
of school but if it's that
and Beyond
I think that's just so much to try and
do in one game but I'm here for it I'm
here for it if that's what they want to
do
looking at the poll right now let me see
we've got 59 yes 41 no in terms of
pre-order we'll leave it up for a little
while longer
couple people who got a PS5 just for
this game
all right I'm catching up on comments
now catching up with comments
trippy moon going to watch every Harry
Potter movie movie the night before the
game drops
Dawson what do you think the most common
house is
you know
I would usually I would say Gryffindor
but the numbers I've seen
dude did we just get another gifted we
did Nico with another gifted membership
who's gonna get this one
who's gonna get that gifted membership
oh I think I just I think I just missed
who it went to
but Nico with the gifted Nico thank you
so much for gifting that membership
it should pop up in the chat as well who
gets it
[Music]
but I want to say
there was a Reddit post not too long ago
about this and again reddit's not
Red's not the total answer on everything
but
I want to say Ravenclaw was the top one
on there I don't know that's an
interesting for you guys what do you
guys think like whenever you see polls
out there
I think trap Travis got got one of the
gifteds nice congratulations Travis
[Music]
Christy with another gifted membership
what is going on you guys thank you so
much JP raven fire welcome to Griffin
just got the gifted membership on that
one
[Music]
thank you guys so much for all the
support tonight
I think everybody's just so glad that
like the stream is holding up and
working
everything's working so far
so far so good
all right here we go I'm gonna do like a
rapid fire trying to catch up with the
comments
and then we'll start uh we'll we'll dive
into some chamber Secrets here
all right but now I have to scroll back
up
to where I left off
you're a wizard Harry
you're a wizard Harry
Potter
[Music]
you're a wizard Harry
okay we answered that it's gonna be
cross platform
Hufflepuff badgers for life
can't help it Christy says enjoy Chrissy
you're a sliver too I don't think I knew
that you were Slytherin
so unrated got one of the gifted
memberships panda hat is back welcome
back panda hat I think we'll be able to
collect chocolate frog cards see
I would love chocolate frog cards
Canon wise they hadn't been invented yet
but we see them on the desk in one of
the trailers I think it was the
the big the big Gameplay trailer I think
we saw them in the room of requirement
on one of the little tables there
so that's almost one where I like I
would kind of be fine with them bending
the cannon a little bit
maybe they can even find a way to where
it works like maybe
I can't remember who invented the wizard
cards right now but maybe the person
that invents the wizard cards maybe it's
like kind of like a Fred and George
thing where they're like entrepreneurs
at Hogwarts so they're like trying to
start this like dude we should we should
create these cards
and so maybe they're like students and
so we get to see them as students I have
no idea that was just completely off the
cuff I don't know if it lines up with
the cannon forgive me if it doesn't
just a guy I was a Hufflepuff over a
decade on Pottermore still a Hufflepuff
sortings are awesomely accurate foreign
[Music]
as well
don't have Twitter never see any tweets
of any kind oh unless so
yeah if it wasn't so big for news I
don't think I'd have Twitter either
honestly
oh what is the next poll idea what is
the gameplay going to feature well it
said they've been listening and so I
feel like everything that people have
been saying is like we want to see
how you take a quest we want to see what
the Spells look like like how does the
action of the game look like so how do I
walk up to an NPC get a quest what does
the menu look like what does the menu
look like when I go to like keep track
of the quest
what does it look like when I go out and
interact with this Quest are there cut
scenes are there like people you talk to
at the quest you know when I'm engaging
in the combat and like the quest
interaction and then how all that ties
in with school I think
is the is the a huge question
huge question
[Music]
Game Awards in December that's a good
idea just a guy yeah I could see that
Jenny welcome
they keep giving us uh more and more to
keep us at right I mean once the
marketing started it started right there
was that two-year period where we were
just like
begging for any little crumb of
information
thankful I say more be later in the fall
yeah I could see that too
[Music]
uh let's see PS5 console and PS5 game
all done after pre-order was released
nice fire burn
[Music]
yeah I wonder how long they'll wait to
release the winter ASMR
his way I mean they could they could do
that like
the game's coming out in February so
maybe like a January for the for the uh
winter ASMR
[Music]
holiday themed robes I would love that
I would love that
I mean we we kind of got decorations
confirmed if you look in the latest
trailer
Travis how's it going
Travis and JP oh that was your tweet
that was you tjs I thought I recognized
that name
I thought I recognized that name man
it's just such a fun Community
everybody's always like
we're always trying to you know ask the
right questions on Twitter get get
official confirmation from Chandler
sharing it with everyone else
Leo l or Leo I just wanted to take the
time and say thank you so much for your
time making all these breakdown videos
hey well thank you so much appreciate
that I love making the videos I love
interacting with you guys so it is it is
my pleasure my pleasure
there you go Jay Rossi with the Canon
details on Henry
also known as Harry Potter was a wizard
who served on the wizard gamut from 1913
to 1921 so yeah the math the math could
work there
1890
yeah math could work
Dylan with another gifted membership man
you guys are going crazy with the gift
of memberships and this one goes to
Ravenclaw T1
congratulations Ravenclaw enjoy your new
emotes
emotes emoji
whatever you'd like to refer to them as
which play do you think it's Gryffindor
yeah I still feel like Gryffindor
probably comes out a little bit on top
just because it's you know
that's the trio right
Northwest Hufflepuff because it takes
all others Ah that's a that's a good
there are a lot of huffleups and
ravenclaws yeah
I mean if we go by the Hogwarts Legacy
trailers
for the common rooms it seems like that
Slytherin is in the lead but again that
could just be
people are so intrigued by that snake
entrance they gotta watch
[Music]
questline for Christmas recent wallpaper
has a tree with candles yes it did it
did
all right I think we're almost caught up
I think we're almost caught up
[Music]
always tag you and expecto and on my
Twitter finds hey I appreciate that yes
that's one of my favorite things is a
wizard when there's any like big news
I'll just
my Twitter app is just exploding
so many tag which I love I love it's
great
now some things every now and then
somebody will find something that hasn't
been widely talked about yet so
you're a wizard Harry
[Music]
welcome to the new subs thank you all
for your support
we uh crossed 30 000 Subs last week guys
thirty thousand subscribers
push for 100k for Hogwarts Legacy
I think we could do it I think we could
do it we need like a couple big videos
but as the game gets closer I feel like
people are gonna be getting more and
more interested in checking out videos
so
all right let's see AJ draws here had a
question oh but Christy with another
gifted membership
man we have got a crazy number of
members now Northwest gaming I just saw
Northwest gaming in the chat Northwest
gaming gifted one of those memberships
right there
awesome thank you Christy and congrats
to Northwest gaming
here's the Tweet again for anybody who
uh missed it earlier
that's the big tweet the big news from
today
all right hold on let me get AJ's
comment here I think they'll have
holiday events like Assassin's Creed
Valhalla and Arkham City for Halloween
Christmas oh yeah I think holidays for
sure
how do you think that policing system
will work prefix faculty Ministry
it just depends like on how big the game
is right like I feel like prefects are
are given
that's something that was in the old
games
[Music]
that's something that was talked about
prominently in the original books is you
know sneaking out and the prefix being
the ones to always make sure everybody
was you know
do what they're supposed to do
[Music]
Amore poet it's impossible for me to get
a gifted membership I have what's called
a branded account oh that excludes you
from receiving gifts no way
I think mine's set up as a branded
account too
yeah it's like how you I guess if you if
you're a brand and you want to have like
multiple channels I think I set mine up
that way in case I ever well I actually
do have multiple channels but I haven't
posted a lot on one of one of them's uh
retro record tour let's plays but I
haven't I haven't posted that much on
there
[Music]
all right so we are caught up spaghetti
in the chat where did you download it
spaghetti if you go to that article
just Google medium
silver laid
Harry Potter and that's those are the
instructions I followed but I'm always
careful of like telling people because I
don't want I have no idea if that link
is still valid or not so that's why I'm
always cautious about giving people like
the exact here's where you go
because I don't want you to I don't want
to mess up your computer so make sure
you make sure you you research it and
make sure that it's still apparently
works because that yeah that was a while
ago that I I got both the uh
um the pce version or the uh philosopher
stone and chamber
dark lord poppy oh my goodness 100 likes
yo let's go
thank you Dylan thank you
oh gotcha Amore poet that makes sense
yeah
that makes sense
uh inner fire I talked about somebody
asked about that earlier so the final
video is done I'm working that one
possibly has a sponsor very likely has a
sponsor but
I have to wait for them to fully approve
it and it's kind of taking a while so
there's a chance it might just get I
might just release it normally but I I'm
hopeful that we're getting close
but it will come out either way like
even if for whatever reason it doesn't
work for this
company that I'm working with if they
decide this video doesn't work for what
they're wanting then that's fine I'll
I'll release it but it is done so it's
it's just a matter of time
laughs
Sinjin see the the poppy chatter has
went on so long that I now I don't know
if people are kidding or not I think
you're probably being serious because I
was in the very same boat you were
but no puppy is not a Lestrange
oh my
so for those of you who don't know like
what are they talking about
expect to go fellow Hogwarts agency
creator
Hufflepuff big fan of Poppy
he has the thing in his chat where
people just love to kind of hate on
Poppy and say that Poppy is the true
evil one poppy is behind it all
and so some people were saying that
Poppy's last name is Lestrange no they
give her name in the trailer guys it's
puppy Sweeting poppy Sweeting is the
last name
or poppy exactly
I get that reference
from Dragon Age oh my goodness
I mean now I feel like Avalanche should
just they should literally just put an
Easter egg in there just for
expecto go like maybe there's a mission
where
you're like in the dorm room in the
Hufflepuff common room or something and
you find this letter that Poppy wrote
and it's just like full of Rage
or a diary like like uh Tom Riddle's
Diary
Sweeting convincingly conveniently nice
name
exactly
oh goodness all right let's fire up this
game here and by all means we're gonna
definitely gonna cheap cheap
the chat going
so I'm gonna minimize let's see
all right I'll need my chat here
all right it's gonna get crazy again you
guys are gonna see like a crazy uh
double OBS window here for a second
actually you know what I think I could
do this let me do this then I can move
it
and now if I do this yeah there we go
okay
all right so close this out
and then I need to pull back up
the chat
over here
and I can pop out the chat perfect
perfect
all right okay fingers crossed everybody
oh let's uh before we start the game let
me in the poll here okay so the final
results on the poll heavy period
Hogwarts so I can see 220 votes 59 yes
41 no
there you go those are the results if I
hit endpoll they should pop up here
now Poppy's scaring me
oh goodness
hey how's it going Chris thanks for
stopping by
foreign
I hope all of the uh companions have
side quests
all right guys so Harry Potter and the
Chamber secrets
I have never played this one
I played
hold on before I start playing we're
gonna make sure that uh
all right I'm gonna check my screen to
make sure everything looks good on this
end okay let's go to video
my gosh resolution 10 24 by 768
all right and then
joystick I'm gonna try to use mouse and
keyboard hopefully
all right new game so see here's where I
was testing it start a new game by
clicking on the slot we're just going to
go to uh
slot two here
we go guys
hopefully this didn't just kill
everything
yes
okay wait it's only showing up on like
half the screen for me though
Harry Potter lived at number four privet
drive with his horrible uncle and aunt
and their hateful son Dudley
they're hateful son Harry was often
locked in his room and even though he is
a wizard he couldn't escape because he
wasn't allowed to use magic when he was
away from school if it looks weird right
now oh my gosh those glasses
feared
I can't see the chat at all right now it
like completely took away the chat must
not go back to Hogwarts I'm gonna let
this get something otter goes back to
Hogwarts he will be immortal Danger
foreign
that's not creepy at all don't be
disappeared and shortly after Harry's
best friend Ron Weasley and his
brother's Fred and George arrived in a
flying Ford and it's always funny when
they're trying to like speed up
everything you know speed up the story
they flew him to their home the borough
where Harry spent the rest of the summer
before traveling by flu powder to Diagon
Alley
Diagon Alley
Harry met up with Ron's sister Ginny and
went with her to flourish and blunts
where the famous wizard oh Ginny and
Harry was signing his latest book
Great Scott is that no
surely not
it is it's Harry Potter
ladies and gentlemen this is the perfect
moment for me to make an important
announcement I have great pleasure in
announcing that I will be taking up the
post of defense against the dark guys I
can't even alt tab right now Grace
I can't even alt tab like the game just
I can't see my mouse
bet you love that didn't you stream's
probably actually down Harry Potter
to even go into a Bookshop without
making the front page
oh my gosh that's Hermione you've got
yourself a girlfriend I suppose your
parents oh no that was Jimmy for a month
to pay for all the books you're going to
need at Hogwarts dang the least I can do
to help out the poor
[Music]
poor their faces man
and the glasses like Harry's glasses
cracks me up
okay come on let me take control hurry
hurry actually I think I don't think
it's expressed
I was gonna say I don't think you get
control until they get what are we going
to do
I know that Dad took the flying car to
work this morning it's parked in Chapman
Cross Road
okay it's your only chance of getting to
school on time
[Music]
loading game loading game
being sure to check that no one was
watching Ron and Harry took off in the
old Ford Anglia
now all we've got to worry about are
airplanes
see anything in here
dude that freaked me out a bit
that was so loud
oh oh I think the car's cutting out come
on car
come on
all right come on finally let me take
control here
are we at Hogwarts yet
gotta be at Hogwarts now right
uh oh
wrong wrong where are you
over here Harry the one big Willow's got
me the whopping Willows got me don't
worry Ron I'll come and get you just
hold on
I can't do anything else hurry up Harry
[Music]
okay am I finally I'm finally in control
all right everything looks
I'm gonna have to see like I cannot
it will not let me out of this window
you guys
I'm afraid to control alt delete
okay I wonder if I can uh
oh dude maybe we need to change the um
the video is all messed up but you can
tell that
I need to get to um yeah let's let's
quit the game
and let's make sure the stream is still
actually functioning
this point
okay
let me see here
all right are we actually
why does Harry look like okay so you
guys could actually see it all right all
right all right
it looks like for me everything is
frozen so
used to love these three games
dude are we actually
I'm not saying any chat pop in but it's
showing me is still live
are we still here
okay all right
like nobody was commenting I was like
what is happening
what has happened did it just completely
kill the stream this is a sign to play
the console version right well I have
the console version I I have all of the
uh I've played through that one on my on
the channel here
but um yeah I was really wanting to play
this one I think it was the I think it
was the resolution maybe that was
throwing everything off and also the
full screen
yeah the game stopped I I stopped I had
to kill the game because the game
wouldn't let me I I couldn't do anything
I couldn't let me let me try this again
here
and I'm just gonna try to set it at a
really small resolution like once the
game loaded I could not alt tab I could
not I couldn't see Chad at all I
couldn't see anything so let's just do
like let's just do 800 by 600
I wish I could just run it run it as
windowed like in a window
if this doesn't work then we might just
have to uh
all right let's here we go here we go I
could lose you guys here I could lose
you guys
oh no yep yep it just it just went crazy
again
oh wait hold on though I do see a little
bit more this time
stop stop stop
all right I know you guys can't see it
right now
because um
I had to turn off that input for a
second
yeah why will it not like I can't get to
OBS at all while this game is running
[Music]
the good
news is the game nothing is cut off for
me now
so it's all looking good on this end oh
perfect yes okay
all right so I think this actually might
work if I can just
get over into obs
yeah you guys got black screens
all right I'm gonna try something
hopefully this doesn't kill the stream
I've gotta try a control delete
because that's the only way I can get
over
actually you know what we're not even
gonna risk it we're not gonna risk it
because we're gonna do I'm just gonna
close out again
I'm gonna Escape I'm gonna quit the game
because now that I know this will work
I'm going to go here
and let's minimize all this let's
minimize all this all right so let's
turn back on
my PC screen yeah this one okay
now
here let me check this before anything
else is the sound on the game too loud
are we good on the sound
imagine playing Hogwarts Legacy at 380
resolution because here here's the bad
part about this is I can't interact with
anything on the OBS side
once I once I pull up have the game
going okay sounds good yeah no sound
there's no sound right now yeah
hey Mary welcome good to see you here
Mary
and I also I'd really like to be able to
pop out my chat so I can actually
so I can actually see you guys
I tried that Sinjin I tried the Windows
key I tried alt tab it will it will not
close out Harry Potter
and the Chamber of Secrets
oh goodness okay so everything looks
good here
I can see the chat I'm gonna try to open
it one more time
how do you get the wallpaper uh this
wallpaper right here
it should be uh
where did they post that one
where did they post that one
task manager hotkey James what's the
task manager Aki
I want to make sure I see it before I
open it up again
you talk about control delete
I mean because that pulls up task
manager or there is there another
hey Nico thank you so much
Luna hey welcome Luna sorry for asking
do I know Alex from podcast now yeah I
know I mean I don't know Alex like
all are you trying you're trying the alt
f4
yeah I mean that will that will
completely shut out of whatever the
active window is Jason yeah
I don't wanna I Wanna Be basically on
most games I'm a single PC setup
obviously
yes I do have a second monitor Sly I do
have a second monitor
but on most games even when I'm
streaming for PC I can like alt Tab and
I can still get over to my other monitor
like where I have the OBS pulled up and
the chat and everything
tried deleting system 32 no I have no
idea I have to control delete task
manager okay so so control delete if I
have to try that during the game Ctrl
shift Escape is the task manager hotkey
okay gotcha let's try that right now
there we go okay nice perfect perfect
all right so I should be able to try
that let's let's try this one more time
we're gonna try to open the game here
yeah right the the window the alt tab
always works for me
but
Harry Potter and the Chamber of Secrets
overtakes everything
yeah
fingers crossed
okay we're probably gonna get the cut
scene again
all right let's see how it looks
oh terrible
it's so small
where are you oh my gosh
I don't think this is gonna work
don't worry Ron I'll come and get you
just hold on
I can't do anything else hurry hurry
hurry
oh my gosh okay
excuse me all right but now
we know let's see uh
task manager oh my gosh everything's so
big
everything's so huge
okay but I should be able to get back to
OBS now
oh yes okay wait I think this is working
I think this is working
all right so now I gotta get back into
smaller and smaller it gets
okay okay okay let's see oh wow dude
this is like OBS from
wait all right hold on guys we're making
progress here oh yes
okay okay
let's get it lined up here
yeah there'll definitely be bars on the
side because it's it's four by three
all right let's try to line it up as
best we can
whole setup blew up yeah like
dude look at the Hogwarts Legacy
background
you guys are getting a nice uh close-up
look here at the games I currently have
installed
oh man all right so now see this is why
I say try download this stuff at your
own risk
all right so now what I need to do is
I need to get everything set up on this
right side
okay perfect there's the chat I can see
the chat I can see the chat now
I'm gonna pull back up the game
no
why is the game not hold on okay let's
try it okay wait wait wait
hover
over here okay there you are can I play
you now
why can't I knock it back in
you can't make this up just so like that
I know right just just load
we were so close look if I hover on it
it shows up maybe if I click up here
why would that be doing that you're a
wizard Harry
closed task wait which task should we
close
Alt Enter
okay wait let me hover
change the resolution to 1080P and it's
filed documents
interesting
closed task manager itself oh yes right
right right right right
do you chat
I thought that was gonna work
Oh I thought that was gonna work for
sure actually
window windows 98.
oh man
try to alt tab into it oh that's a good
idea now
I love the ideas
I love the ideas
like you should be able to
yeah you guys can see that too right
like
oh it's not like it's not pulling
anything up because the the resolution
is just like
everything's just dead
as a result of the resolution all right
well let's try this let's let's close it
and now that we
it's peeves again
well at least we're still here we're
still live we're still together
that that's a good that's good force
close and restart the game I'm that's
what I'm thinking JC there might be a
moment where everything is huge
on your all's end
yeah it's it says it's not responding at
all all right so let's end the task
okay desktop is okay good this is
actually good that you guys are seeing
the desktop blown up like this this is
actually good
I'm gonna close out of everything else
too basically everything that I can
close out I'm I'm closing out
all right we're good on everything here
it's OBS and I need Chrome up because
that's how I have the chat showing right
now
yeah Scott exactly Scott did you turn it
did you blow in the cartridge Oh wait
we're PC here right or PC
Okay so
oh wait I just saw this comment from uh
just want to make sure I'm in the uh
from Luna oh yeah sorry Luna I couldn't
see your follow-up because
everything's going crazy right now James
appreciate it glad you love the videos
but you were asking if I know Alec I
just know I I I know who Alex is but
yeah I don't know him like personally or
anything I just want to make sure I'm in
the right environment there's some
YouTubers and streamers excited for
Hogwarts still act high and mighty
shamey for thinking different oh no no
no no now we're chill as a
random mosquito just like
dude we're having like some crate what
is going on tonight
just a mosquito just like just just fell
I thought it was a spider at first
I don't I don't hate like I don't panic
when I see spiders like some people but
I mean if if a spider just descended on
me at this point I I think we would have
to take it as a sign that we do not need
to play the game
extra if you could walk me through that
I don't want to derail things too much
if you could walk me through the file
thing
I will at first I'm gonna try this if
this works I don't really care about the
resolution but if you could actually
like if I can get it to run at 1080 that
would be great I could try that some
other time
all right here we go again like why can
I not just run it in windowed mode
I wonder if I try software renderer
oh wow that one's 512 by 384. oh my gosh
that'd be so small
I wish like I wish we could just run it
windowed right here that'd be great
love your legacy videos by far the most
enjoyed in detail hey Scott appreciate
that thank you oh I can't wait
February's gonna be insane dude that's
gonna be insane Northwest all my all my
videos are like this oh
set your resolution the same in your
game and in your PC settings for your
monitor
you can turn on Window mode in game
settings once you watch the game
JC let's go okay if I could do that I'm
fine with I'll make everything else work
you can screen mirror as if you're
watching on YouTube
is your computer plugged in okay let me
hold on guys I've got a uh Windows 98
floppy boot disk drive no I I don't I
don't actually
but um if I could do that for main game
okay let's hit okay
and let's go load game we're gonna have
to watch that stupid cut scene again
all right here we go hold on everybody
hold on
hold on for the ride here
let's see where we end up
oh no my chat Windows moved again I
can't
okay
you guys could see it better that's good
that's very good as you guys can see it
now it's actually like
somewhat filling the screen
but it that's how it looks on my screen
too where are you going all the way down
over here Harry the one thing Willows
got me I think the whopping wolves got
him guys
[Music]
nothing else hurry up Harry
all right so let's see now somebody said
we can do windowed mode
uh
uh that's probably the wrong area for it
oh sound and video
color depth 16 oh wait I'm not I'm
afraid
what the heck why not let's see what
happens
oh dude that looks a lot better
yes
[Music]
okay
now where is Window I don't see I don't
see windowed mode
foreign
come on Crank It Up I want I want some
high object detail here
[Music]
okay resume game sound and video input
menu quick game
[Music]
unless I'm just missing it I do not see
how to do
and unfortunately like I do need
oh man
I do need to see my chat
cool cursor I know right don't you love
the wand
like by the time we finally get this
figured out it's like time for me to end
the Stream
I have to rescue Ron that's my objective
challenges wizard dueling
quidditch menu go to the map Secrets
birdie bot we can tree bark loverworm
mucus
oh you were thinking of philosopher
stone JC philosopher okay
all right well
my second monitor has done something
really weird
to where my chat is actually showing
prominently at the moment so how do
things look for you guys right now is
there anything cut off I mean I know the
black the black borders on the left and
right that's expected
but is there anything else
is everything else look pretty good
Alt Enter okay we'll try that
it's perfect Northwest says it looks
fine nothing seems to be cut off to get
1080 you have to edit the game ah okay
I'll try that I'll try that after after
stream especially if we're because I can
actually see the chat right now
my second monitor is doing something
very weird but I can't see the chat I
will try the uh I will try the all inter
thing
and no luck
no luck on the Alt Enter
it's these old windows games
[Music]
all right well this is this is good for
me I can make this work as long as it
looks good for you guys okay perfect
all right so let's see if we can save
her on here
all right I think you guys can see
everything there
okay it is uh we started the stream at
8 30 my time it is now 9 50.
had a nice little chat at the beginning
though a little little video
troubleshooting here just a little bit
just a little bit
but now we're good now we're good
actually it wasn't even gonna play on
this screen I was gonna play on the
screen where I am
where the game takes up the whole screen
but you know what we're not we're not
even gonna mess with it we're just gonna
we're just gonna stay right here where
the chat stays on screen
all right well right away the the
controls feel
[Music]
man a better than Sorcerer's Stone for
sure
but still a little bit
quite a bit wonky all right so what do
we need to do we need to rescue Ron all
right
[Music]
okay that's that's kind of uh unexpected
there all right let me just slide by
here
all right
oh chest already spell to cast a spell
press and hold the left button
[Music]
we can do that
2 A.M in England oh my gosh well thank
you for hanging out sporting the street
I just have to walk into them this is a
Chamber of Secrets as a Target to
activate them on the PC
it does look I know it probably doesn't
look great to you guys but it looks a
lot better than loss for stone and
here's something that I actually love
that they did you start off
with I'm pretty sure I start off with
all the spells that you finish
the first game with
which makes sense right I mean you're in
here too this is a safe it'd be weird if
you didn't get them to save why do his
glasses go all weird
when you faint your game will
automatically revert to the point where
and when you last touched a Save Book
okay
Aloha Mora
looks very good right I mean clearly
they had
they had a good good sense of the art
style and everything it was great
yeah it does look a lot better than okay
wait a second that's blocked off there
so we need to go this way I just want to
make sure there's nothing else I can
interact with there
dude this is note to self this is why I
took off a panda on that luggage to push
it to that ledge that's why I prefer the
console but this is a really old
old game
all right so I think we just need to
send it this way
[Music]
the 3D glasses yeah on Dumbledore
exactly Mew store they are on Dumbledore
in the philosopher stone game I'm
assuming they're the same here okay do
we just jump down I think so
sorry Ron okay I thought I had more time
okay I still I thought I had more time
guess not okay Ron hold on before I
rescue you I just
I need to I need to uh
need to search for some unlockables here
it's just a chocolate frog
wait get back here chocolate frog okay
good I needed to restore my health there
anyway
could you imagine like the Whomping
walls got you and you're like hold on I
just need to let me unlock this chest
here
ah okay you gotta wait for that the big
one okay so there's one
there's two and then here's the here's
there's a long one now see if
shifts repindo on this project for pindo
dude the all-purpose spell sensitive
nippendo could take care of everything
[Music]
see a sensitive spot right there oh wow
it's almost like they they March much
appreciated
anyone else hear a weird audio delayed
no don't tell me that Dreamer
don't tell me that
go back wait what I need to go back for
me did we miss something
I love flying lizard card somewhere
we better get a move on we don't want
professors I don't know amazing cjb
I feel like it at bare minimum I feel
like we'll get uh some Easter eggs like
there's gotta be a reference to it
[Music]
I don't think we can get whatever uh
cjb I think it was cjb or no Northwest
gaming said go back Mr wall
behind it oh I see it now
I see it
what was back there was it a wizard card
oh
see that's like so annoying I should I
should absolutely be able to wait could
I like blast it again and get him to
raise up
oh white beetle play all the Harry
Potter games on PC again
play with all the patches that I have no
idea
oh it's beans okay I'm not worried about
the beans
not only does lumos but thank you though
I can't believe I walked right by that
so lumos can reveal the magic platforms
now too
oh my gosh cjb I mean if we were if we
were parcel Mount that would make sense
yeah
but otherwise it probably would jump run
to the ledge and press the right Mouse
button
with all the uh gifted memberships
tonight
every flavor beans I should collect as
many as I can they'll come in handy
later I bet they will
and did I see we have Mr Rookwood here
in the chat hanging out we need to get
onto this to this Edge over here
for Pinder will fix any full Pinto
it's just like the answer for everything
yeah I know Ron I know where I need to
get
hopefully you're not annoying as you are
anyways
and then let me explore for a bit Ron
is that it okay yeah like see I know
what to do Ron but let me just look
around I we already missed a secret we
already missed a secret wall Ron because
you were I don't know Tangled Up with
the whopping Willow or something and you
were so eager
to get for us to get you out of there
ah
yeah here's what button to press
but it's just DLC
I go back and forth on that one in terms
of if I would want it and if I would
expect it I feel like
I think clearly they want to make money
they may already have some DLC planned
and if they don't I feel like they will
listen a lot to Fan feedback I really do
and if quidditch is the one that keeps
coming up well they already have flying
builds into the game we know flying's in
the game
so possibly they would do it but then
the other part of me is like
would we rather have oh
wouldn't we rather have a story DLC
I think I would rather have some like a
story DLC over quidditch but I I hear
you though like I think it would be
clearly a lot of people want it
oh there's a wizard card let's go dude
this is a guns wizard God there are 50
of these scattered throughout Hogwarts
each time you collect 10 uniforms you're
given a permanent stamina increase
February everyone will remember your
name to access the full Magi and look at
the wizard cards you've collected thus
far yeah I
Mary expecto girls got me I mean
he makes a lot of good points all right
first up we have our first wizard card
hesper Starkey number seven here
1881 would you look at that ladies and
gentlemen would you look at that
dude
she should be a first year in Hogwarts
Legacy
right it's my math right on that she's
born in 1881. oh no she wouldn't
because she would be not she would be
nine in 1890. Harry doesn't start until
he's 11.
so she'd be two years away from starting
which who studied the use of phases of
the moon in post making so she would she
would have been in school with
Dumbledore then
hesper Starkey
[Music]
I have no idea about that voice actor
thing
oh is it cutting off the date for you
guys
it's right down here at the bottom
maybe it's cutting it off to the point
where you all are unable to see it
all right
see what's inside the suit of armor what
no beans okay there we go they were just
a little bit delayed there
foreign
s all right let's see how many times can
we looks like that's it
the beans it's it's so delayed when they
pop out
I do like how once you've exhausted like
everything that's possible from that it
goes away so you can't even
so that keeps you from being really
confused into just like keep spamming it
over and over
oh just too small to read gotcha
[Music]
Charles that's a great question that I
still
do not know the answer to you're a
wizard Harry I still don't know the
answer hey Commander welcome thank you
so much for subbing to the channel
I go back and forth Commander I mean
obviously we're gonna have a ton of high
horses going out at least we'll be dry
when we get you hear what this cutscene
says come on we better get up to the
school
[Music]
all righty
okay I just want to make sure before I
drop down there's not anything
I would be losing access to up here
no hidden doors there all right yeah I'm
really torn on it
what do you guys think like
because there are people are kind of
divided a lot of people say they want to
see me live stream it a lot of people
say they would much rather they want me
to upload it to YouTube after the fact
Danny becoming a YouTube member thank
you so much Danny welcome
uh you just unlocked some pretty slick
Emoji I'm pretty proud of them can't get
out that one all right I'm not trying to
get out Harry I'm trying to explore calm
down
the store is look tight
I know these games were made for kids
but just let me explore a little bit
please
for crying out loud oh wait was there
more I missed some beans
but yeah welcome Danny I appreciate you
stopping by hanging out and choosing to
become a member James love this game
used to use mods to run around as Goyle
in the Slytherin common room that's
great Northwest you're gonna do both
I had thought about doing like a a good
or evil one of the two
wait what is there supposed to be
[Music]
is this like
is he just commenting on the stars or is
there something that I was supposed to
okay all right he's gonna tell me I
thought I thought so Harry I thought I I
had no idea it was locked man like I
just I couldn't tell
but yeah I thought about doing like a
good play through and oh wait was this
gonna open or unlock just more beans
thought about doing one as like a
YouTube only it's like I just I don't
live stream it and then doing the other
one like either vice versa like let's
say I do good for YouTube only and then
I do an evil playthrough that I live
stream all right just making sure that
didn't unlock the door or anything
yeah that's true as well Zone Luna I'll
be getting on PC right
oh
I hope I mean if the modding Community
really
jumps on board with the game it's gonna
be insane like you see what people have
been able to do with
Minecraft in terms of making Harry
Potter stuff for it okay Ron I know
you're trying to rush me on dude but I
definitely feel like there's stuff to
unlock around here so just give me a
little bit to explore on just give me a
little bit
I'm a little more
beans
yeah I can't wait to see how fast people
make a Quidditch game whoa wait is that
another that's another chest up there
look at that like right there
oh dude okay we're gonna try to figure
out how to get over there
[Music]
oh yeah yeah absolutely right now the
rain has stopped the live streams would
be archived
my biggest thing is somebody else was
saying that I I could always
um
[Music]
so many seek
I had heard that one of the reasons that
a lot of people loved this version is
all the secrets I mean that totally
looks like there's supposed to be
something
the The Dilemma is some people think
it's a different experience when you
watch a YouTube let's play where
it's been pre-recorded which I agree it
is a different experience
oh I don't have that spell yet though
probably incendio maybe or
I guess we'll have to come back out here
once we get that
so the argument is for those people that
just like that that YouTube only
upload that's like it was never live
stream it it is a bit of a different
feel
because there's no there's no chat
interaction right it's more of a it's
more about the actual commentary whereas
like this live stream right now we're
kind of having the chat we're chatting a
lot as we go let's get out that way
but yeah either way I would definitely
save them
now the one thing I am still trying to
figure out is like where
where my Let's Plays will ultimately
live if it's the main Channel or if it's
I made a separate Channel retro record
retro recorder let's plays
so far I think I only have
Elden ring playthroughs on there
[Music]
dude that is so
wait what
okay that was so weird how it didn't
didn't take the first time
all right so I don't guess we have this
spell yet but
now we know that we definitely need to
come back here
[Music]
did play Quidditch World Cup I didn't
play that one either growing up oh my
gosh and there's
dude just this one little area there are
secrets everywhere
which I don't even know if I have the
ability to get all of these just yet I
don't think I I know I don't because we
can't
we don't have that spell to be able to
burn down the thorns
now the one thing I do want to try and
figure out is if I can get
the one that's like up there
I think there was was there a brightness
setting
is
that does not look much brighter
like I know you you guys can actually
see it better than I can but with this
with this big light shining onto me for
the for the webcam
it makes it really hard to see such a
dark screen right here
all right let me just crank it all the
way up and see if it actually makes any
difference I don't see I don't see any
dirt it's probably just the brightness
of the menu or something
aggrid on PS1 right
[Music]
any reason not to do it on the other
channel you mean like any reason not to
do it on the main Channel
YouTube is kind of
I shouldn't say it's weird it's like the
way the algorithm works and I'm still a
little bit unclear on this part as well
like like when I post let's plays
there are a lot of you guys that love
them and that's why I keep doing them
because I know there are people that
that enjoy them but they don't do nearly
as well as the kind of the main Hogwarts
Legacy videos do
it's it's gotten a lot better but there
used to be this thing where it was it
would pretty clearly hurt your YouTube
channel because
it sends signal to YouTube that
oh
people aren't interested my my core
audience they're not interested in this
video they're not clicking on this video
so the click-through rate of that video
ends up being really low which basically
results in that video not getting pushed
to anybody whereas if you put it only on
a dedicated let's play Channel then I
would 100 anybody who goes and
subscribes to my let's play Channel like
you have to go out of your way to do
that like that's the only thing I'm
uploading there you have to be 100
interested in Let's Plays because that's
literally all it would be is Let's Plays
so it's an interesting little uh
not really a debate but but there's just
it's it's like a data question an
analytics question
not even so much copyright issues no not
copyright issues
more just like YouTube algorithm issues
all right I think I've done all I can
out here for right now
because I don't have access to some of
the spell yet oh that's totally gonna be
a spell that we get later
and this looks like like this one right
here looks like it's going to be
something that will Spring you up
all right so let's go on in for now
and then there's another one up there I
have no idea how to get to that one
[Music]
Luna I love quotational cup
don't like Tire real quick to the right
remember I've never played I know it's I
know it's a thing that people have like
made a game
where it's like the there's actually a
person who is the snitch right
wow this feels much like
this is much smaller completely
different layout than the console
version
hey Josh how's it going
won't spoil the Spells nice all right
all right you're a wizard Harry
hey Micah thank you so much for
subscribing thank you thank you
so yeah I'm thinking like
[Music]
I'm finishing out my Prisoner of Azkaban
Let's Plays for sure here on the main
Channel
but then after that it's a bit of a
question like if I go back I'd have to
edit this one down obviously because we
had we had several false starts like
this this as a live stream will
will stay here on YouTube
here on YouTube it will stay here on
like the main Channel but I might
eventually go and pull out just the part
where we're streaming it here
and post that on the let's play Channel
[Music]
but then also YouTube has a thing where
they don't really like duplicate content
so if it detects this as big
Germany chamber
the house point ceremony chamber what
[Music]
oh yikes
I know
no cannot cast a spell on that yet
uh it's just retro reckon tour let's
Place JP is the other one
[Music]
spell we already said
oh I pr I probably know several of
several of them
incendio I bet is is one that we'll need
basically basketball dodgeball and track
with a smattering of wrestling if you're
a beater ah interesting
okay I don't think there's anything we
can do in this room yet nobody's earned
points but I love this room this is
pretty cool
dude let's take a look at the icons here
Hufflepuff
Gryffindor
Slytherin man that's an interesting
green
and then we have Ravenclaw which it
looks like
yeah that's an eagle right
second I thought it was a raven but
or no is it a raven
it's kind of hard to tell when it's all
one solid color
but the wing the wings definitely look
more
eagle-like
who knows
the gelatinous cube yeah we need uh
scourgeify I think I think if it's the
same as what it was in the other games
whoa look at this look at the graphics
you guys the Reflections in the mirror
are you kidding me
hey here's a very famous statue
alrighty then
okay
shall we go for another
all right the laughter's still going
laughter's still happening okay we're
done I think we're done with the
laughter now
all right I think this is the one I'd
think this that's the one-eyed witch
right I think so
all right so we can't go that way I love
how the music just stopped by the way
too
the music just died
knocked that actually scared me right
it's just like so unexpected because the
music's gone right now the music's
dropped out because I've explored too
much so the soundtrack just just ended
oh wait wait let's see what this one's
gonna be
dude that's
and it's kind of a creepy statue though
right
hey Tara thank you so much for the Super
Chat finally made a live always teaching
dog training classes and miss out wow
that is awesome though that your uh your
dog trainer very cool
[Music]
thank you so much for the Super Chat
Show and support of the channel I am
glad as well that you got to catch one
of our live streams yeah we are we are
pretty late
pretty late
how's it going Rob welcome hi IQ Warrior
what's up
all right let's see what wizard card
that was
Andross the Invincible okay wait so
where'd my other wizard card go
wait
hello
11 through 20.
it was like number seven or something
oh wait there's different categories in
this one okay we got bronze okay so
hesper was in the bronze category then
we step it up to Silver and then we have
gold here
oh Rob it's not an emulator actually it
is um there's a website uh if you search
medium
m-e-d-i-u-n if you just Google this
medium silver laid
l-a-i-d-e Harry Potter
you'll get an article that tells you how
to get it up and running on Windows 10.
I cannot speak to the validity because
it's an old article
so I don't want I don't want anybody
mess up the compete or anything but
that's what worked for me
so Andrew's the Invincible ancient Greek
alleged to have been the only known
wizard to produce a Patronus the size of
a giant
that is interesting since Wizarding
World slash Pottermore
has given a bunch of people dragon
patronuses
very interesting
hey yeah weird categorization right
Hogwarts 2020 Edition
oh man that'd be interesting
all right so we already went we checked
there I don't think okay Ron's over
there see if we go in this this path
this door is locked well
ah I will look into that high IQ Warrior
we had a whole
this is a whole big issue even getting
it started because it wouldn't let me
get into my OBS once I had the game
pulled up so that's why it kind of looks
all weird and wonky right now but yeah I
think we're running at uh 800 by 600
right now is our resolution
but yeah some other people were saying
that there are some things you can try
some things you can do in the game files
to get it running at a higher res whoa
okay
so what is the spider web
almost thought it was something we
should interact with maybe we can later
oh wait this was the main area
okay this is not where I thought we were
all right so we already did I think we
did everything there okay relax Ron just
relax dude
tally man
Andross feel like that name is familiar
Andros I'm pretty sure it was a
character in uh Star Fox right let's go
to bed I thought you'd have the password
why would I have the password why would
I have it I've been with you since he
got here you're right I better know who
would have it there you are oh and she
just appears right on time I heard the
most incredible story about you two
getting expelled yeah we didn't have the
run-in with Snape Hermione please we're
tired could you just tell us what the
password is
wattle bird hey thank you Nico it's good
to see you yeah I need to get that uh
uh
brilliant entrance
mum's Furious by the way Freddie George
should hear about the bean trading
system we've set up all right let's hear
30 bullets every flavor beans Fred
myself and several of our Associates
have set up trading opportunities
throughout Hogwarts some of us will
occasionally have an item to trade if
you have enough beans we'll trade with
you where are we supposed to get all
these beans are you kidding me Harry all
over the place are you kidding me I want
to find them you should have enough to
start trading in no time
it'll be a pleasure doing business with
you I'm sure
some of the mirrors in portraits can
have alohomora
I think you're right I think you're
right
we definitely just there was like a
random wall earlier what's inside
the cheers I know it's Aloha Harry and
Ron became Gryffindor Heroes due to
their little accident with them come
people always pointed out the comments
Harry slept well hello come forward to
his first day at Hogwarts
good morning Harry yeah the cat somebody
said that I saw somebody said the castle
looks dead so different unrecognized so
much smaller brilliant writer then the
defense against the dark Hearts console
versions follow us
but I I 100 agree with whoever it was
that told me about like the secrets like
just already
you can tell how many Secrets They are
packed in I want to see if I can go back
up to the common room and look around
there's the portrait of the Gryffindor
common room
a soundtrack so the Emoji that we have
in the chat
I am working on some shirts with those
but
I don't want to just do the icon alone
so I'm working
I'm working to make it where it works
better for a t-shirt basically but I am
working on that that's a great idea
heading for the common room are we oh
well let me go back in
what's a bird
nice okay we can good I want to see if
we can explore here
the thing about the merch is like
obviously you got to be careful that
you're not violating any any copyrights
or anything
so it's not like Harry Potter houses
Gryffindor Ravenclaw
it's um
you know we have to focus on the animals
[Music]
but yeah I am I am definitely planning
to do those I actually have two more
designs so we've got we've got the
Merlin design up on the shop right now
thank you for the new Subs by the way
welcome the Merlin design is up on the
shop
and I have two more that have already
been designed and I'm just saving them
one I'm gonna release in October for
Halloween because it's steamed around
the unforgivables
there's you guys a little teaser for
that one and then the other one is
related to wizards chess
and then then I'm gonna do something for
the for the four as well
four animals I'll have to wait to use
careful you'll knock my prefect badge
crooked oh relax Percy
your prefect badge is fine
exactly they're snake Badgers Eagles and
lions
[Music]
okay we can't go in there dude like just
look look at this common room
compared to what we're gonna be getting
in Hogwarts Legacy man
look at it like this is it
which
they did they did what they could right
with the times
but man I mean this is just gonna be
such a massive massive difference I mean
honestly the console version uh
common rooms are are much bigger than
this
wait what are you guys talking about you
can jump from jump from where what do
you mean
jump from up top
[Music]
I can't can't wait to AKA prefect
oh I don't think that'll be a I don't
think that'll be possible
whoa
[Music]
oh you took damage too nice nice thanks
for thanks for telling me that guys
thanks for pointing that out
all right so we're heading back out
yeah Jeremy Soleil
so good oh hello there camera pretty
effect to help people not to tell them
what to what do now Move Along
[Music]
what
[Music]
I came a prefect not to tell people what
to do so now I'm going to tell you what
to do all right let's see if anything
see ah I want to see if anything's
changed up here because
you how about you get out of here
do we get more beans now
no okay so nothing has changed all right
so the little puzzle here reset but
nothing has changed all right we'll have
to remember that and then I'm assuming
it's like this is actually the way we're
supposed to go right there
just gonna double check Ron don't start
panicking looks like another spell oh
dude
okay the witch is like not going crazy
now but this guy he's like holding out
you got some games sorry I just sold my
very last item a moment ago oh did you
come on buddy
how about you I haven't got anything to
trade at the moment come back later when
I've had a chance to replenish I forgot
the damage
the astronomer had exclusive
it kind of did
[Music]
explore the Restricted Section
oh it's gonna be so good
yeah I'm loving the secrets of this one
better than the console I am liking the
layout of Hogwarts much less
dude like where is everything is it even
multiple okay here we go I was about to
say is it
even gonna be multiple levels
David just became a channel member Harry
we'll get this David thank you so much
welcome thank you for becoming a channel
member showing your support and love of
the Stream
very much appreciated
okay now okay this is better this is
better this is better oh dude look at
that wizard card right up at the very
very top
I always love the portraits
like don't you wonder where they got all
of these
[Music]
and I love the idea of having this
oh oh are you gonna trade okay
mucus for a limited time only what are
you trading press on the yes button to
accept the trade or the no button to for
beans
I don't think I want Flawless yet just
wait until we see what it actually
called to find oh are they
drive a hard bargain
okay what do you have sorry I've run out
of stuff I have to come back later
even better in the challenges
[Music]
oh not silver blade silver laid
s-i-l-v-e-r space
l-a-i-d-e and you just do medium medium
is like the website medium.com medium
silver laid Harry Potter
and it should be like the first or
second result on Google
one of the greatest things about the
portraits in The Wizarding World how
they can leave it exactly yes like how
you see some gone sometimes oh sorry I
just of course you did dude okay they're
like let's put all these students all
over the place but none of them are able
to sell because they're all out
go ahead and save the game right here
and let us see
uh Ethel rid the ever-ready medieval
dates I know and famous for taking
offense at nothing and cursing
innocent bystanders died in jail
that's a famous
what that's a famous wizard okay
yeah so I guess later we're gonna
interact or unlock the ability to
interact with these we can't just yet
mucus why do we need that exactly is
still purple like they were on Console
oh I forgot to I think they were yellow
think it was yellow we just we just
looked at the
room where they tally the points
somebody asked again about am I going to
stream Hogwarts Legacy I'm still trying
to decide if it's like going to be a
stream
is that McGonagall
professor
or is that oh that's Mrs Norris
that's Mrs Norris
oh my gosh that's so cool
as she's just roaming the castle that's
a nice touch
I like that
I actually really like that
potion ingredient ah okay so I probably
will need it later on I want to see what
Fred and George have first though I
don't want to spend it wait so I'm I'm
back out I don't think I'm supposed to
be here
I'm back out here we need to go through
here
all right so then we came out here all
right will it let me go up to the top
will the stairs appear
hey it's is that Nick yep that's Nick
hello Harry
oh hello Nick
even after all these years I still find
new secrets in Hogwarts that's
incredible here's a special area that
you can unlock only if you collect all
40 Silver wizard cards oh that's awesome
dude
for every 10 silver wizard cards you
collect you'll get a key that will allow
you to open one of the four locks on the
door
nice see if you can find all 40 Silver
Wizards oh you know you know we got to
be searching and the grounds
hey Luna thanks for stopping by and
hanging out good to chat with you
appreciate your support on the on the
stream and on the videos
and then you can get ingredients in
expiration okay perfect I figured it was
probably uh probably something like that
but then somebody was saying
uh had a glitch oh that made Hufflepuff
purple it was caused by a glitch
oh it's gonna be cool can't wait to see
what's back there
thought older games were less hand I
know right
not in this case all right let's keep
going up I want to see if we can get
that that wizard card yet
I don't even know where Ron said to go
for uh
let's just go oh wait wait wait I kind
of want to explore this now though
Aurora
more beans
I feel like Fred and George will have
good stuff when it comes to uh
where you want to spend your beans wait
why is this
interesting that it's out alohomora
[Music]
okay so that one's done
no my allergies hey my allergies are a
lot better now careless dreamer a lot a
lot better
still not a hundred percent oh nice
but I am way better than we were last
week
[Music]
yeah I definitely remember seeing that
in other games where where Hufflepuff
would be uh purple
you remember seeing that
we're just kind of exploring here
honestly
I'm not in a real hurry to get to the
class
[Music]
okay so we have some we have that locked
door but then we have three doors that
do not appear to be oh that one's locked
through this door as well let me just
make sure
yep yep yep
I wonder why this door is locked exactly
Logan exactly see I always say it like
like he says it in this game alohomora
but then I mean technically I think it
is alohomora
and I was I was saying it in a video one
time and there were a couple people who
were like
the pronunciation of
alohomora is terrible
it's like okay come on
come on now
[Music]
well come on then
all right so
why were you late yeah just oh Mrs Doris
is up here now you remember where it is
don't you
[Music]
oh and now I'm here miss Norris
filch might be lurking nearby
wait what oh well gee I had a crash you
want to I find
Mr Harry Potter and a broken airplane
maybe filters magic after us
Argus filch the caretaker was loathed by
every student at Hogwarts some thought
his cat Mrs Norris spied or students
honestly it just fell
it's already happening
what was that
oh hey what are you talking about hey is
she about to get petrified right a voice
hearing voices won't get you off
I'll mark this down against you now Move
Along while I clean this up
why won't you just let me like repair
I've been here
why don't you just let me repair it dude
[Music]
secret trick to get unlimited beans from
the toilets
[Music]
I love that it's that it's from the
toilets okay can I just like pop by Mrs
Norris thank you because uh you know we
gotta collect those beans
relax
all right does this one not okay yes yes
there we go
all right now
how do we get up there
[Music]
oh man
whoa what is that
oh it's like a
chain a rope and some
like metal hooks on each end
all right so I'm just gonna check this
out here I did see Ron was at the end of
the hall there dude there that's just so
creepy
that's what all the creepy laughs
speaking of creepy laughs oh my gosh
that latest Hogwarts Legacy trailer are
you kidding me oh we're in the hospital
wing
the hospital waiting
I mean Hogwarts Legacy guys
there's gonna be some scary moments in
that game
not quite like survival horror but
dude they are they are embracing
the darkness for sure
oh you didn't say it Harry why didn't
you say it
the god
Okay so we've got we got four now on
this category
[Music]
um what is that name Almer ulmeric
sawbridge
the river troll in question was believed
to be one of the largest ever to exist
in Britain having a weight of one ton
Tara with another Super Chat Tara thank
you so much we'd be live streaming
Hogwarts Legacy gameplay when it comes
out
and then it cut off the rest of your
comment
if you don't mind Tara just comment it
in the chat as well
I I don't know if you were here when we
were first setting the game up
it's like completely broken my OBS to
where I can't see all the chat so I
can't click on your Super Chat and see
your full comment so if you just if you
comment will you be live streaming how
it works like as a gameplay when it
comes to comes out got the pre-order and
debating taking off work for a couple
days to play
I can't decide Chad was asking me
earlier
I mean obviously there's going to be a
ton of Harry Potter content out on the
channel right a ton of content
I can't decide on whether it's going to
be live streamed or whether it's going
to be
just posted on YouTube later
because I feel like all of us are going
to be wanting to play the game so I feel
like even if I'm live streaming I don't
feel like there'll be that many people
watching dude is that Dumbledore
oh no it's uh palm free
I just saw the long white I thought it
was Dumbledore's long white hair Madam
Humphrey hello can we talk
safety first Harry Safety First
I love that safety first Harry
I will definitely be taking time off
though I think
Tara I think I'll definitely be taking
some time off because we're going to be
cranking out so many videos
so many videos
that laugh at the end of the trailer
just because it's oh dang exclusive for
PlayStation
they're just laughing at everyone else
uh black widow or hold on Kayla says the
lock symbol in the pause menu tells you
how many secrets are in each area
oh
[Music]
oh my goodness okay wait so let's see if
it counts this as a secret so I was at
one right now
all right so we just got that knocked
over no
oh my goodness
[Music]
are you serious okay let's see if the
chest hurts
surely the chest counts
another wizard card let's go wait what
the chest is not a secret
[Music]
still a one out of ten
Safety First when she's really saying I
don't want to see you in here at all
exactly
ah but we do we do see her in this year
and now she's coming in here what the
heck
definitely calling into the work the day
it comes out
PS4 until you get PS5 hey soundtrack
have a good night thank you for hanging
out good to see you again
can't wait to see how other students
interact with our character depending on
our house
this is one time I'm so happy I'm My Own
Boss nice
the 10 counts for the entire staircase
area oh wow
considering buying the game on PS5 later
but I can get on PC
special sound when you find a secret oh
about to be on the listening out for
that so maybe this whole area was
the secret
but now that we're back here I don't
really feel like there's a whole lot
this is just
seems like palm tree's office area
now once we figure out we oh there's
something up there though
[Music]
unless we get access to being able to
use those potion the cauldrons down
there oh this looks like something I
should be able to interact with no okay
[Music]
no no no no no all right those of you
who have played the game just tell me
this much don't tell me what it is tell
me if I have everything I need right now
to be able to get
that up there
or if I don't have everything I need so
I have everything I need I'll sit here
and figure it out if I don't have
everything I need then I don't want to
waste my time
I know yeah the waving of the hands in
the air when he's jumping hey Darren
how's it going
okay
thank you guys thank you yes all right
that that keeps me from just like
beating my head against the wall trying
to figure out what the secret is in
there
all right so we're good there we're good
there all right let's go out of the
hospital wing
and I think I'll head back down and
we'll try to take our fence against the
dark arts class
which I believe is what they said is our
first class
[Music]
oh the music
there it is
filch still here cleaning that up when
he could have just gotten a wizard to
[Music]
hit repero
oh like that sound right there
that was it
oh my gosh that's cool
man I just hope I hope Hogwarts like
because he has so many little secrets
and details like that please
get it
another secret in the first part of the
hospital Wing oh
oh I hear the little uh gnomes
I haven't seen one yet yep there they
are
take that dude
a lot more beans I feel like out of
chests in this game
[Music]
all right can we
wait is there a Crouch button
[Music]
actually don't know
[Music]
okay let me see
is there a Crouch okay forward backward
turn left turn right jump use one drink
potion strafe Left strafe Right map skip
cutsy oh wait is there a map oh there is
a map
Harry is here
okay fourth floor Hospital wing
[Music]
it's an interesting map layout here
first floor third floor second floor
fourth floor
okay
all right
I'm I'm not really with you
throw the gnome
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that's so good
[Music]
oh now I can't get that bean though
because it's
because it's stuck
thanks for the pro oh there we go just
had to go behind thanks for the pro tip
on
it's like what is the point of this hole
here is that just showing me hey he
lives in there nah he can actually Chuck
him back in there
I love it all right Phil's just still
there cleaning up there's Ron
come on dude
all right and then somebody said I
missed the secret at the first part of
the hospital wing
gonna go check that and then we're gonna
come back here
lumos and accio is probably going to be
spells that I have right they're just
kind of like some good go-to spells to
always have
readily available which we don't even
really know I mean how the equipping is
going to work just yet
okay so we we interacted with that guy
already
so it's probably something in this room
right here yo
Wait nothing happened
maybe we have to hit all of them
oh my gosh I love this game so much
already
oh
[Music]
I just like I I expected to hear the
Zelda
there we go there's the Harry Potter
sound for it
I saw
yo shout out who was that was that Mew
store who said that
thank you view store let's go dude let's
go all right so let's go see that was
our um
second silver one now Queen Maeve
legendary witch who trained young
Sorcerers in Ireland prior to the
establishment of Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry and then we
already had uh Andross here
so we already got five in this section
and there's 50. oh my gosh
so we got 101
yep 101 wizard cards my math is right
hit any portrait you see some will have
secrets oh okay
yeah that's how we got all those right
there
expecting more spooky gameplay since
Halloween is coming up I'm just so hyped
at what Chandler said that they're
actually going to show us more gameplay
okay I didn't think there were any
pictures in this room just wanted to be
sure
that's that's all I need to see dude
that's all I need to see I want to see
some combat like the moment-to-moment
gameplay and I want to see how the
classes work
show me those two things and like I
don't need to see anything else I'm
ready to go
I'm ready to go
oh
you guys called it
and there's another Secret
more beans let's see all right that's
four out of ten on the secrets nice job
let's go chat
let's go
no they're not available on Steam I
don't believe
these this one definitely isn't they uh
I think they have some of the newer ones
like maybe Lego I think the Lego games
are on there
but I don't think they have any of the
uh like Deathly Hallows or Port of the
Phoenix I don't think they have any of
those oh wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
another secret let's go come on where's
your card dude ready for a wizard card
oh wow that one had a lot of beans
though we're at 154. can I hear
chocolate frog somewhere
yes the chocolate frog
I'll be I'll definitely be playing as my
own house to start for my first
playthrough
multiple playthroughs absolutely but
I'll start off with Gryffindor
welcome to defense again here we go all
right we made it it's an introduction
unnecessary but I'll Delight you with
one anyway I am gilderoy Lockhart order
of Merlin third Merlin honorary member
of the dark force Defense League and
five-time winner of which Weekly's most
charming smile award ah I see you've all
bought a complete set of my books yeah
nice about a seller today looks like her
we shall be learning the Richter
sempered spell Richard sempra is very
useful when stunning certain pesky
creatures it's another spell that
Cornish pixie I mispronounced he wants
to be first Harry Potter will you step
down here please some people say rectum
simply you do not want to say rectums
I always thought it was rectum simpra
but no it's Richter simpra clear your
mind completely Harry don't even think
about me
concentrate wait is he actually gonna
teach me something useful see the wand
it's going to move its way
something important to the exact point
when the one I'm in shot over the arrows
hit the corresponding Arrow key this
exercise has three parts you must Arrow
key all of the arrows correctly in order
to progress to the next round ready to
try round one okay maybe begin
this is so different
[Music]
I do not like it
I don't like it I like the old way
you've Advanced to the next round five
points to Gryffindor Five Points begin
I was I was looking at chat
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay all right well
might as well let it get back around
all right here we go
I thought I had a moment to look over
and read but nope you gotta do more
well done Harry you've Advanced to the
next round how many rounds are there
points to Gryffindor round three okay
beginning I'm ready
this is so weird
is this DDR or something
what
fabulous what is happening aren't you
glad you've learned from the likes of me
you've now completed the exercise
15 points to Gryffindor
you've learned victims you didn't do as
well as I did
now how about a turn in the spell
practice I've seen a couple of those
High Q Warrior from uh flandrew YouTuber
flandrew he's done a couple welcome to
my famous
Tower try to get to it as quickly as you
can if the challenge timer reaches zero
before you have the completion I'm just
like you lose the challenge I'm taken
aback Lockhart is actually teaching us
something collecting challenge stars
will boost your timer and completely
inept in this game try to get this menu
as possible the higher your score is
when you complete the challenge the more
house points I will award you oh geez
the pressure good luck I was barely
paying attention one go
what Lockhart do you not understand I
like I have I'm trying to oh he's got
his own statue here already little pests
that like to shoot hot flame out of
well actually
the
they can use flipender to push them
around
okay all right and then we gotta get it
this indicates that's a fire crab placed
on or nearby the symbol he's a teacher
right a world famous author try and use
flipendos
plate yeah I like the other method
better on the Spells the uh
Rich assembly of having to trace it
[Music]
all the statues of Lockhart man
okay like I don't like when they put
time on things because now I feel like
I'm gonna miss stuff
whoa
oh see like this like this secret right
here
oh and it was a wizard card and Beads oh
my gosh let's go
all right so I don't think we need to do
anything else I think we can just jump
right here oh but we don't want to miss
that beam
I heard a I heard a frog randomly there
he is
okay
make sure there's nothing here to unlock
that's a giant orange snail avoid
touching
line Trails the acid that they support
okay trust me I know trust me I know
we'll stun them and then you can use
flipendo to push them around
all right so I guess we do have to drop
down though I don't think we can take on
this part from up here
oh I don't like that
[Music]
whoa that one was really close
I'm just gonna go ahead and get both
foreign
and then I'm guessing we can't reach the
Stars yet
gonna need these
all right and then we're gonna push this
one back
oh dude he's launching at me from in
there
nicely done Harry
a right yeah he's actually he's actually
teaching
I'm just I'm that's why I'm so shocked
okay got them both
all right so now
I think we're good
all right let's move on
[Music]
I don't even know if you have to do this
I don't think you do they're giving me
birdieball means for it so
I will go ahead
gnomes oh we got the Gnomes back they
will try to steal your birds Mr Moe
found your channel because
um
hey glad you found the channel
welcome thanks for stopping by
get rid of them that is a gnome hole
this is where gnomes come from and where
they allowed to deposit stolen that is a
gnome hold of these holes to permanently
get out of them Chad already told me you
cannot climb Chad already told me that
those are no moles all right so
you can get a little bit close blast
them
where are you
back into your gnome hole what
there we go
had to line them up just right all right
got a little save point right here nice
shout out to the person in chat who said
to make sure I use spells on portraits
oh goodness there's a lot on that one
all right so let's head up now
I don't really need that at this point
so I'm just gonna
save it
here's a card all right I hope the timer
doesn't work when I pause
Myron wagtail 1970 to present lead
singer of popular Wizarding band the
weird sisters
JP ear puns
going to cost you 10 points
uh time is taking let's go yes yes yes
we need to
oh I don't like this
what
I don't like this
no I knew he was gonna try to blast me
from the other side
okay we got that one
Nick December
let me tell you man
I like a lot better than the other ones
I think this one has some really good
gameplay ideas
two birdie bought every flavor beans
I know right
get in there
get in the
fire crab compartment
whatever that little area is
see you were made for that little spot
right there okay I think we climb up on
both sides
[Music]
we've got 3 000 seconds you guys I'm not
too worried
[Music]
yep might as well just hey hey
back here
oh I would have laughed if I would have
taken damage from that ball
right after grabbing the chocolate frog
oh wait so what's the plan this guy I'm
just here to throw me off
yep he definitely is
oh my gosh there's still so much up here
no oh there's another star in there
let's go
[Music]
uh nothing else in there I think we're
good I think we're good
[Music]
for the best score you can try again
later oh nice nice
oh you like that I don't think I was
supposed to
do that but
yeah I love that they'll let you try
again later okay so wait three thousand
three Thirty okay I'm looking here
looking around in here
heathcote Barbary
okay so it was not counting my time
that's good when I had it paused
hey where am I supposed to blast you to
nowhere I guess
I think it's so weird how eventually the
music just stops
definitely your new PG it's normal
yeah I don't know why they uh oh my
goodness wait whoa we have our first
puzzle here
how are you hi IQ Warrior oh my goodness
sayak you were becoming a channel member
no thank you so much dude welcome okay
so we need the face no not that one
nope
okay right there
IQ Warrior has been a long time
supporter of the channel
so much for showing Love by becoming a
channel member there oh wait whoa whoa
whoa hold up now hold up
I don't want to miss out on some Secrets
here
and I think I just did
no
no oh that's so frustrating
I thought you would do one thing that
would unlock all the paths but
yeah show us this new emotes high IQ
Warrior
you should go back later yeah that is
true that is true I'd be really upset if
you couldn't
and Tara
another Channel member Tara thank you so
much wait whoa what why is this
it threw me off having a portrait in
there
Tara showing love becoming a channel
member as well
yeah so Channel memberships guys on
YouTube it's a little bit different than
how it works on I don't know how many of
you are familiar with twitch at all so
on Twitch you get ad free viewing on the
channel plus emotes and all that
I don't think it gets you actually I
only think it shows ads if I click to
run ads I could be wrong about that
I could be wrong but you might have to
see them when you first click on the
Stream
but you do get access to the emotes you
get access to a there's a community page
that sometimes I post
comments and feedback for channel
members only so I get some good feedback
from just the channel members and then
you also get discounted merch as well I
think I put like a 15 off code
if you're a channel member
so honestly it's just a way to to show
show support of the stream really and
try to try to give a few a few perks
back to to throw your way so thank you
all so much man we've added vetted a lot
of channel members tonight
don't see as unless you click okay nice
or probably probably like when you first
click on the video that's how it always
works for me like when I hop in
one of the expecto goes live streams
like I'll see it when I um
when I first click in to the Stream
jump up here
jump over there
and jump over there come on Harry
I hear another frog
I I'm already seeing why a lot of people
say this is their favorite Harry Potter
game
already seeing why
I mean just I wish they had
man like imagine if this team
but they had been given more time and
resources too
do all the games
I mean they were like the progression
from the first game to this game
there are so many great ideas already I
mean I'm in like the first what hour
hour and a half of the game or something
which I know is not a super long game I
don't think it's as long as
oh dude this is weird
okay I don't know if there's anywhere
I'm supposed to
blast these guys on this one
John I don't remember this level
oh thank you Nico yeah showing people
how to uh
yeah they don't make the membership
things blatantly obvious okay we've got
seven out of 10 Stars
yeah sorry guys I'm not reading chat as
much they've got us on a timer here
and I don't know when video games put me
on a timer I want the high score
frustrating
it's like you're you're putting me on a
timer and you're giving me secrets
that's the thing I don't like like if if
I'm gonna be able to explore and look
around and don't
timer please
actually let me look around and explore
and then put me on a timer for other
things
all right got you pretty quick
oh come on get in there
all right got him on both sides unlock
the star that's eight got two more stars
to go
another little treasure here to unlock
and another wizard
wait what just happened
oh dude we unlocked a second health bar
that was pretty quick I feel like
orsino thrustin 1976 to present plays
drums with popular Wizarding band the
weird sisters all right we've already
got 10 in this category two in silver
category
and I love how so far we've actually
we're actually going in order
all right
pindo on this
like see I'm on a timer there's this
area right here
Wartortle gang hey thank you so much for
subscribing to the channel okay that's
where I already have been
don't need to worry about going in there
all right
two more two more two more we need two
more
and we're gonna need four of those fire
crabs
think they're fire crabs
every time every 10 bronze card you get
one extra health bar nice
first run dude challenge second go back
that's probably a good
or I would probably do it the other way
like first run is secret the second run
is when you're going for speed
oh wait is this the final star oh I
missed one oh no I didn't miss one it's
in there
it's in there
whoa dude he is launching that fire far
away
just taking aim
is it a fire crab or is it a blast ended
screwed
okay that's low enough now right oh no
it's definitely not but wait am I not
gonna get
it
am I not gonna get that other star down
there
oh
I don't know if I should run back down
and look for that other star
[Music]
try to get as much of the house points
before leaving this challenge oh okay
for the next part of the story
check the pit ah darn it
all right I should go back down then all
right let me drop right here
I'm going back
I'm going back down
oh wait you need to push them all first
oh no oh I missed one anyway
maybe I didn't
okay so how do we get in there
[Music]
is it over here oh no
no
oh dude we're killing our time
okay see that's the star right there I
want to be able to get that one
it didn't land in Us in the specific
area on the pit
oh that one that I just that I just uh
fixed
wait jump down into the pit
is that a joke
wait really you guys are serious
jump down in the pit okay all right all
right I'm trusting you
I'm trusting you
jeez it almost killed me
but
it worked it worked
wow I'm actually shocked by that I
thought you guys were trolling me
I thought you guys were messing with me
oh goodness not another
card a it was worth it though worth it
wizard card and already bought minions
and a gnome
which we're gonna take and throw in
there get a few more birdie about me
apparently just one more birdie bot Bean
[Music]
from the base no we got no time for that
oh and this is the other star let's go
let's go chat for the wind
no other Secrets here okay good good
good all right now we're going we're
going we're gone we're gone we're out
[Music]
we don't have time for that Rob we can't
we can't just like casually stroll down
to the bottom I should have just jumped
from the top to see if he could survive
it
with two health bars
figure the lock chest in the common room
or so we could easily access our gear
without running up could be that yeah
because you would think like the logic
would be like why wouldn't it just be
at in the trunk that's in your room
maybe it is maybe maybe it's in both
spots
I was like I don't trust
stop well done Mr Potter you have
completed my ripple separate it's
remaining time now because
your personal high score
nine out of ten wait what
no
no I thought the final one counted as
10.
we missed one
[Music]
oh my gosh dude
I thought I had them all
Mr chest in one of the rooms
disappointed
I'm so disappointed wait so are we done
okay I was about to say what happens now
Harry do we your housewife ceremonies
about oh that's fine that's why you
wanted me to get I'll show you where it
is you wanted me to make sure I had high
points follow you oh wait okay I'm
coming don't run off
don't leave me
oh dude Dumbledore's in here everyone
for those of you who have trouble with
the yellow I am Albus Dumbledore
Headmaster of humble it's our first time
eating Dumbledore come to the very first
we've already started a ceremony oh his
glasses are fixed in this one the house
they look a lot better than
Philosopher's Stone it's a visit to the
bean
the length of the visit depends on how
many more points they have bonus and
replace house
oh it appears too we're dominating is in
the lead Harry it looks like you get to
visit the bonus Bean room the bonus baby
oh my gosh oh wait limited time again no
not the limited time oh my gosh they're
actually everywhere
and they're not even telling me how much
time I have
oh my gosh
I love this and I hate this
we are is there a limit to the beans
because we are racking up in here
oh man I could see like there's a
strategy to this
there's a strategy I guarantee there's
like a an ideal
set path
for gaining maximum beans
so good oh my gosh they're everywhere
the bonus Bean room Harry that sounds
like something out of Willy Wonka does
it not
hello Charlie you've unlocked the bonus
Bean room
enjoy
oh no we don't have this spell yet this
little like spring
we're about to run out of time anyway
come on come on come on come on come on
oh they're just blasting all over the
place
hey we racked up though that's pretty
good
that's pretty good I'll take that
honey there you are Kevin Sorbo hey AJ
you caught it practice Harry none of the
other teams so we'll have a good head
start but I haven't had any footage you
can eat later at lunch follow me to the
Quidditch pitch I haven't had lunch
all over Woods like you can eat later
dude relax I haven't hit a save point in
a while man I feel like we need a save
point hello
what okay hi
you trying to be interested in what do
you have okay what do you have I have a
silver wizard card oh absolutely yes I
will trade
wait did she just charge me
but she's got more
she just charged me 299.
patronage she charged me she charged me
299 beans
oh my goodness she ripped me off
Glinda chatok 1964 to present popular
presenter of The wwn Wizarding wireless
network program witching hour
yeah expensive I feel like she kind of
ripped me off there
she kind of ripped me off I just I just
spammed yes bye absolutely okay so this
is the area where we started
yeah I could find that elsewhere I bet
you know best Harry yes I do
more beans yeah definitely gonna need to
replenish after
charges 290 something beans come on
all right and we also need a uh we need
a save point and we need a chocolate
frog card or chocolate frog
that's why you want the unlimited beans
exactly
oh there's another chest right here
that wizard card still up there just
taunting me can I actually use the chest
to uh dude imagine imagine oh
oh man
yeah clearly they want you to use this
spell that's right there
would have been awesome though pardon me
I beg your pardon
famous Harry Potter
can't even go to a Bookshop without
making the front page
stand in front of the chest without
moving you collect the beans a lot
faster oh like if I just
if I just hit the unlock oh my good look
dude what the
she is booking it man she is oh here's
another one
First Years
First Years this way I already got this
chest I 100 got this chest right here I
guess they couldn't reset
okay let's stand here
oh you mean you probably mean like stand
just right on top of it I bet they do if
you if you get them that way probably is
faster
would you be interested in trying no you
ripped me off
yeah I have I'm undecided about the
Hogwarts Legacy oh but I try Dari okay
and if I think you have one types of
mucus
I think it'll be like a percent thing
like you unlock
I don't know or maybe like cast that
spell just a little bit faster yo
there's friend George okay that's who I
wanted to talk to
yep you're totally well you get most of
them but then a couple of them did fly
off to this side there want to trade we
buy them both passive savings time I
have a Nimbus 2001 the best model
available excuse me public
oh 700 don't know when I'll have these
again though
dude I have quidditch armor just like
the armor
oh my gosh you guys are customer is
always right even in cases like this 500
wait why do I need quidditch armor
wouldn't it be quidditch gear
[Music]
those ingredients can be expensive ah
good to know I don't even know if I'm
supposed to go in here yet but
[Music]
he has a Nimbus 2001 oh dude this is
Hagrid's
good old Hagrid's Hut good old hat
something about the way he said that man
good old
hagrance
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I'm sorry Haggard I hope this
doesn't harm your pigs
look calm down
calm down and just I'll be gone I'll be
gone momentarily
oh let's go hairy
come on I am going to grab these beads
right here oh dude Haggard's actually
here he's like what are you doing out
here
[Music]
what is what if you what if you fed them
Hagrid
Hagrid
hello sir
I want to know about the pigs though
what have you done and like dude Vic
December does nothing
what
oh my gosh we could save at that safe
that was so loud
[Music]
you thought the voice in the trailer was
crazy right
man where are you going Hagrid
[Music]
this is the Forbidden Forest
what
just
he didn't do anything
I thought he was just gonna disappear
honestly
all right let's see can we go in here
all right
save
okay so now we at least have a safe
point there
Tomatoes got nothing on those swine
Captain tiger hey welcome never made it
to a street before appreciate you
stopping by and hanging out we are uh we
kind of Switched things up a bit tonight
still talking Hogwarts Legacy talking
Harry Potter talking gaming in general
but also playing Harry Potter and the
Chamber of Secrets on PC
the scar on Harry Potter's forehead
moves around like a snake or so I heard
I'm hoping that Hufflepuff wins the
house Cup this year
we're just gonna pretend like I'm not
like like I'm not him
oh my goodness this game is cracking me
up I love it sorry no time to talk yeah
you look like you're trying to get that
wizard card that's up there
all right you know what what time is it
oh man it's already 11 20 my time yeah I
think this is gonna be a good spot to uh
we we just saved right there so I think
we saved it a good spot
I'm gonna go ahead and quit out of the
game here
everything's gonna Flash and Go Crazy
for a bit
because
I'm gonna have to remember this next
time man because there were so many
things that went
awry when I tried to stream that game
we're gonna have to play around with the
uh
the resolution and everything like that
to see if we can get it running at a
higher resolution
but you know what it worked we made it
happen so now I need to shrink this back
down
a lot
because that's how tiny the game was we
had to blow it up so everybody could see
it
all right so now let's actually move you
back here
[Music]
we go
all right
it's the wrong window
wrong window
why would she say that right I mean
right to his face
Tara sure help a puffle
right
oh man
YouTuber Joker Alex that has a guide on
setting up the games on Modern PC oh I
need to okay
Joker Alex I'm gonna put that in my
notes right now
right now
okay dude
the Apple update has just changed notes
okay let me go in here
let's see who did you say joker Alex
Joker Alex
I'll just say HP PC
and that should make me remember
[Music]
try Monday live streams is our Monday is
better for you Tara
foreign
I would love to stream during the
afternoons
or even during the mornings
but
I have a regular nine to five
that I met during the day so
I was gonna actually I had a day off
work last Friday I was gonna try to
stream then but that's when I was so
sick from with my allergy
Breakout
hey Tom welcome yeah thank you
[Music]
yeah I captain tiger I'm usually pretty
we usually start around 8 30. normally I
only go for about two hours or so I say
that there's no normal we've been four
hours we've been three hours
[Music]
James says uh interested in watching a
Tom Riddle series based on him as a
child
all the way oh you're talking about a TV
series
[Music]
to the moment that he kills Harry's
parents interesting
yeah there's still a lot of untapped
story in the Harry Potter Universe for
sure although
I think they need to let
let some different people get involved
because
I'm just not a fan of the direction the
movies have David Yates I'm kind of over
David Yates at this point
and don't even get me started on cursed
child
as a play I've heard it's actually very
good as a play but the written oh man
oh man
when are we gonna be streaming this
again good question I don't know
I feel like we still had good
interaction during the stream it's it's
definitely a different vibe when I'm
doing a stream of a game versus when I'm
purely here like this
like when I throw this screen on or
[Music]
this screen right here on people just
know that it's meant to be like we're
hanging out we're interacting we're
chatting I definitely feel like the
comments weren't as frequent as when
we're in the game
but I definitely want to keep doing game
streamers game streams as well and kind
of uh interspersing them occasionally
Mondays are your day off ah gotcha
yeah you do get uh wallpapers in The
Wizarding World account
thank you Tom appreciate that
got lucky catching a stream high IQ just
as I get off work yet Tuesday it's just
kind of a day that's I don't know that
it'll always be the day that works best
but right now it's the day that
seems to work best for me hey have a
good night Mary
even as a play the plot is a bit Yeah
the plot the plot's the issue
[Music]
I'm kind of with you Kayla I've gotta
with you despite them calling it The
Eighth book I'm just like
oh don't print that on the back of the
cover please
these are great when it's a slow news
week that's a that's a good point Tara
yeah maybe for like when we uh
I also I do want to try some some twitch
streams as well
I think
so we've got some new people here in the
chat tonight so the newer ones probably
don't know but I long ago I streamed on
Twitch a couple nights a week then I
went all in on the YouTube thing and had
no time for twitch
and I've built such a great audience on
YouTube I'm kind of like why do I Really
Wanna
split that but
AJ draws with the 70
z-a-r I'm not sure what currency that is
but regardless four dollar okay there it
is four dollars uh AJ draws thank you so
much
I'm glad you enjoyed it yeah it's fun
it's fun to go back and play some of the
old games and I'm I I really enjoyed
that too I've never played that one
some of the games are kind of a grind
kind of hard to get through but that was
awesome I really enjoyed that
I'm loving the gameplay
the gameplay of it is really really nice
streak face to face is best when it's
like new gameplay right right right
right almost morning for you mu store
wow
yeah I feel like I
on YouTube we have kind of a more
worldwide
reach as well I don't know we get a lot
of people from
other countries popping in get more but
AJ dude don't you do not have to give
anything you you being here chatting
hanging out is support Enough by the way
and AJ I always anytime
AJ is uh the artist for my Twitter
profile picture so AJ did a really
awesome drawing of Hogwarts I can see
content creators
and it is a
it's it's all of us like cast some some
people are casting their Patronus
summer cat like I think uh expecto goes
got a little Mandrake it's so good it's
so good
5 29 a.m for you oh my gosh
I want to Captain tiger yeah I
definitely want to this is kind of like
this tonight was really our first jump
into it whenever I'm doing console or
streaming modern games we won't have
nearly the technical
issues that we had tonight for those of
you who weren't here at the beginning it
was it was a chore to get it up and
running because the game has to run at a
different resolution and then it just
like completely shifted the whole screen
I couldn't see anything I needed to an
obs
but yeah I kind of want to stream the
new God of War when it comes out
I kind of want to stream that
and replay the old one before it comes
out but
I say that and we're running out of time
new drawing coming up oh that's right I
saw you uh reaching out to some people
[Music]
I can't wait to see it can't wait to see
it
11 30 for Tom 8 30 p.m for Tara yeah I'm
I'm 11 30 as well Tom
[Music]
yeah I enjoy streaming the games I mean
that's really why I got into the whole
twitch and YouTube thing in the first
place because I had such a fun time
streaming and interacting
I would also like to do a stream at some
point where we play something together I
don't know if you guys have ever done
the Jack box thing
the Jack box thing is really fun our
radio gaming yo what is up
welcome our R-rated game I believe it's
the first time I've seen our radiant be
able to check out one of our live
streams but thank you for stopping by
and hanging out
we uh just wrapped up streaming some old
school Harry Potter and the Chamber of
Secrets
yeah jackbox is a lot of fun and then
like even like like I'd love to do like
Fall Guys and fortnite but
then you're only like there's a very
small amount of people that can get in
any game
torchlights or Diablo
Diablos I play Diablo
usually asleep by now I know right I'm
like are you guys awake are you are you
sleepwalking right now and you've hopped
on YouTube
thought I said R-rated gaming
no no no our rate our radiant gaming
they're basically the exact opposite of
our rated gaming
they are family-friendly content
creators as well
Good Vibes all around
very chill very fun husband wife they do
a lot of stuff together
and then a lot of stuff separate too so
you'll you'll notice some of them in uh
I love Ashley's videos of like the uh oh
what was I watching the other day she
had a video up about I think it was like
switch cat accessories I was like this
is so good
our our radiant gaming yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
fortnite I would never touch flaw guys
maybe someday I keep hoping uh that that
Multiverse this game will add Harry
Potter to it
there's a lot of WB stuff in there
I'm expecting T for teen high IQ
I'd be shocked if it's anything except a
T for teen over here
really really shocked
although
although that latest trailer looked
pretty dark
pretty dark
but I don't know man I just don't think
they'll go mature there are too many
although Harry Potter fans have grown up
now but I still feel like there's enough
of a younger audience
that they can't afford to go in
[Music]
listening to order the Phoenix on the
way home nice uh
can feel everything changing wait what
do you mean what do you mean changing
you talk about it in the book
because it's yeah
four book four is really kind of like
that the end of four
it's a whole different ball game
the end of Order of the Phoenix oh my
gosh
so good
so good feels like it's getting yeah
yeah yeah
you're in a you're in a different
with what happens at the end of four
spoilers guys
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire he
didn't know
Voldemort gets Resurrected
sorry if you didn't know that
Voldemort gets resurrected bit of a game
changer
bit of a game changer at the end of that
one
I love that you that you haven't been
spoiled on the story though our radiant
I love it
read you the books again recently they
are still so good I need to do a reread
Tom I do
I definitely need to do a reread
yeah I kind of enjoy multiverses as well
I haven't played a lot of it
but my son and I hopped around and just
did you know kind of got a feel for what
it's like I'm a big Smash Brothers fan
so I was I was at home right away
I'm I don't know that I'm a fan of their
monetization though
oh
I don't know that I'm a fan of the
monetization
I wish you would have like at least you
had characters
Zorua the fox can you do a video for how
to get old HP PC games to work modern
Windows struggling can barely run the
third game
thank you so much for the Super Chat
very much appreciated so this this has
been a big question tonight all right
let me just show you guys so I'm real
first I will preface this the reason I'm
so like
I'm not trying to be intentionally cagey
I promise but anytime you're dealing
with like I don't want to basically lead
you guys wrong and
get you into trouble downloading
something that's gonna mess up your
computer so I'm just gonna show you how
I went about it so it's a Google here
and there's an article silver laid or
hold on we need a medium silver laid
Airy Potter
okay so see this this second result
right here
installing Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone so this is from
April 2020.
these are the steps that I used I'm not
saying you should use them
do your own research
I don't I do not want to be responsible
for
[Music]
breaking someone's computer
getting you in trouble with
downloading things you shouldn't be
downloading this is a method that
someone has put out online
that worked for me so
that that's it right there guys
so yeah if anybody tries to get back
here you just Google that right there
medium silver laid Harry Potter
second result right here it'll walk you
through the whole thing Windows 10
and then the same place where you do the
first game second game as well
so I I don't
I feel bad because I don't want to make
a video on it because I don't know what
like
it just gets into that weird legal gray
area I don't know what YouTube stance is
on I mean because this isn't even like
an emulator question like you you cannot
buy this game anymore
you can't buy it
so
even if you bought it used like I don't
think you could get it
because I I owned Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone I had gosh I
probably still have them somewhere
if I didn't get like just throw them out
or something once I got it upgraded
upgraded machine
um but yeah it's it's kind of a
different story when you're not dealing
with modern games
Windows XP uh interesting Arcane got the
game running stuck at the first lesson
because the graphics are glitching oh so
much that you can't trace the line
I feel like I might have had that
problem too
and
[Music]
they go through a couple of different
fix options here
the bottom
I know our radiant that's just amazing
haven't been spoiled it's abandonware
requires a cracked mono version to run
on Modern Windows because it's broken
DRM software there you go
[Music]
can't buy it second hand it's like two
dollars
do you mean you can buy it
because I feel like even if you like if
you went and bought it on eBay the
the the code's not going to work right
like the
what do they even call it
the third game scripts will stop working
oh interesting
well thank you for the super chat again
I I apolog you don't have to keep doing
the super chat but thank you very much
for your support of the stream so I I
have zero experience with the the PC
Prisoner of Azkaban
uh Prisoner of Azkaban I had to buy a
physical hard copy
so I have a physical hard copy of
Prisoner of Azkaban the console version
but I know that's it sounds like you're
trying to run the PC version so
I don't know that would help you much
but the console version those are easy I
mean you can buy those on eBay fairly
cheap for most of them or even at your
local
used game store
windows 12.
ah all the code on the manual should
work so if you bought interesting okay I
didn't know that I didn't know if they
were like activated and then once they
were activated they were done
I didn't know how that worked
I have played rocket League Captain
tiger yeah I think I have the platinum
trophy on PS4 for Rocket League Windows
12 is that even a thing yet are we just
on Windows 11.
all right guys it's been fun it's been
real hope you guys had a great time
tonight I certainly had had fun we
worked through the technical issues we
made it happen thank you for all just
crazy number of new members tonight guys
crazy number of new members
uh so thank you all very much keep an
eye out on the channel we're gonna have
more videos hitting this week our video
that went up yesterday
is just like taking off like crazy by
far our
our most
it's just taken off ridiculously sub
only chat they support the games to
steam
oh yeah so the subway you shouldn't have
to don't you shouldn't have to do a
super chat for that though
if you sub to the channel
that's free see subbing on YouTube is a
little bit different if you just want to
sub and then unsub you know feel free
just to chat we have I have that turned
on just to prevent the Bots and things
yeah
so there's a setting where you could so
only people subscribe to the channel can
can chat in the window there but thank
you very much I mean thank you for your
support appreciate the donations but
yeah if you just like if you just
subscribe to the channel the little red
subscribe button that's free there's no
charge for that so you can um even if
you don't want to stay subscribe which
is fine then you could just you could
just unsubscribe later
hey David good to see you man thank you
for hanging out
nice long chat to be part of man some of
you been here since since we started
let's go Tom Snipes have a good night
Tom or good morning good afternoon good
evening whatever it may be for all of
you guys
it would be nice if they brought him
back in some way but
at this point it's like
I'd want to see them like
upres almost like a remaster you know
remaster or something
all right guys so I'm gonna go ahead and
uh wrap things up again if you're not uh
follow me over on Twitter you can follow
me at retro wrecking tour I always post
updates there on the channel uh and kind
of what we're doing as far as the live
streams go I'm gonna hit the insert ad
here as we close out so if you stick
around and watch that it'll support the
channel if you close out it's all good
too but I'm gonna hit that I'm gonna go
ahead and um hit the end screen then
we'll hit the ad and then we'll call
today so thank you all for hanging out
hope you all have a fantastic rest of
your week
and I'll talk to you again